Damn sam style.
Got Kale in the first round.
Ain't done.
Gonna we're,
we're a,
we're alive.
Sorry,
we're late.
But that's just how shit goes.
Um,
this is a fight companion podcast.
Have you ever heard one of these before?
Expect chaos.
Expect a lot of talking over.
Expect very little up.
This is not like a regular podcast.
If you listen to this,
like,
wow,
they're going to talk about some cool shit maybe.
But what we're actually doing is watching fights and during the,
during the fights,
while they're playing off live,
we're going to be talking to Eddie Bravo's here.
Edgy.
Thank you for him on a bunch of Niles.
Abi.
Marcus is in this lesson.
Take Fletcher just has entered the domiciles,
the big Tait.
Fletcher hollow more feminine when,
when Brian Town is here,
say hi to the world and find calendar.
I'll do whatever you say.
And Brendan's name,
motherfucking shop is also here.
The fight has already started.
We got three minutes and 30 seconds on the clock left in the round.
First fight,
Maureen Morrows and Valerie and a turno Latino gang banging it is.
This is the first fight.
Uh,
and if you're watching this live,
you will probably be about 10 to 15 seconds behind the actual law.
She shut her lights down for a second there.
That's that weird moment when when someone's legs give out polling,
look at this empty hole.
I like the get
to the baby.
She's trying to catch the half guard did girl on the bottom.
But you know who stopped a chocolate Dell rampage.
Stop check the with elbows to the body.
Remember that.
But from side control like that with a downward elbowed,
I know you don't see that often.
We not supposed to even on the body and not even supposed to throw it out.
Now you see knees so stupid from side control.
Can't even throw a downward elbow to the thigh.
No,
12 to six,
right?
Yeah.
That's so stupid.
It's so super old school.
We have a seat for young Tait Fletcher.
It's an old school rule.
Was it Joe Wic?
Cause they were saying a karate move with ranking.
Right.
This is true story breaking boards 12 to six.
So like that shit so dangerous.
It was actually the athletic commission when John McCarthy met with them.
Big John McCarthy way back in the day.
He told me this,
that they were,
they were so scared because they had seen ESPN like two o'clock in the morning.
White dudes blip breaking cinder blocks with so
many other way though.
And I,
is that the most powerful fucking strike?
Uh,
no.
Like he'll fucking spinning heel and take you into the next,
the same kind of shit.
They break with her shoes with shoe.
It's just not here.
Your heel or shit.
There's nothing tougher than your healing and shit.
Yeah,
your voice doesn't hurt.
Like you can kick someone in the head with your heel and it doesn't hurt like
you,
you break the shit out of your hands.
One is the last time you ever heard of someone breaking their heel by kicking
someone.
Look at this girl has got some pretty clever Jujitsu and the triangle.
She's only got the head in there,
but this pitch camp bereave Valerie turning a eternal,
I shouldn't say bitch cause I do work for this organization,
not in the protocol.
Be Professional that that's a really weird position.
Hey,
listen,
just control.
It's not necessarily doing anything,
but people have gone out from no arm triangles.
That's a fact.
People have gone unconscious and you need to have short legs.
You need something else in those needed an army.
They shouldn't,
should be pushing their own online.
You should shut the fuck up right now probably man.
When it comes to touch me again and I know you don't know anything I do.
I don't know,
but you know one thing that does work though is the fucking leg scissors dudes
and people do go to sleep with that leg.
Leg Scissors.
Yeah.
I agree with it.
Even though it is that we're trying is a little different.
Especially at a high level.
There's,
you're not fucking right,
but it is valid.
The turnover,
she had a high level,
which Jujitsu,
I know her striking is really good,
but she could go for Lexus are right here.
If she untangled their legs is a different animal under the Chin though.
Look at that.
That's nasty.
She's stretching our neck out.
That is going to be taller after whenever I'm called,
I can't help but if it comes to chin,
it's like pushing too.
She's,
she's in trouble.
Anytime I'm caught in something like this and I can't get my head out,
my main goal if I can't get my head out is to do the exact same thing to them
and it's like,
dude,
I got you too crazy.
I just want to let go together.
That's let go together word right out of my mouth and he goes,
this,
this girl is not letting go.
Man.
This is really interesting.
This is a lot of energy on your legs to it is.
It is at least stopping it.
They're not staying on one.
What does,
he was about this.
God,
I'll be fram oil filter.
Oil Change done right.
The Fram Cam Cam,
I appreciate what you were saying.
I missed you or don't.
Don't let him talk Jujitsu.
You don't know fucking Chin before I fight.
I can't.
It's always brought her
coco butter.
Yeah.
Yeah,
the Indians out.
Yeah.
I think you need a bottle opener.
Brothers hold on a second store,
but I didn't say no downward elbows open that can't.
Brian,
you're on the microphone.
You know this is a podcast,
but I'm talking about boy Tait Fletcher.
He and I have a connection.
Abra,
your your boy from Texas.
Uh,
Daniel Jolly.
Prior jogging.
We have a tough,
tough first fights off.
That's a hell of a first fight to give somebody too.
I mean,
they're both newcomers though.
This Canadian kid,
Latvian dude who's like a killer.
They were tough.
I went to college with Dan will tell you that right hand.
Nice.
Right here.
I'll tell you what though,
that girl did recover and that was a funky position.
She had Valerie and
got back up.
Man,
I am so fired up for December 12th you guys should all make a point of let's,
let's all try to head out to Vegas for the December 12th event.
That's how mad event dude,
which Chris Weidman,
Chris Weidman takes on Luke.
Robbie Lawler takes on Carlos condit,
Aldo and McGregor,
which probably won't know Lawler conduct's in Australia.
Oh,
that's right.
It's not Lola.
Kind of witness it.
The other Conor Mcgregor,
all this is one of the fight is one of the big fight on that whole hold on that
for you.
Hold on.
That might be right.
[inaudible] Romero.
Is it?
That's a mother fucking to tell you right now,
dude.
We should do,
we should do a fight companion from there,
Joe.
Fuck yeah.
On a Friday.
Yeah.
The biggest card of the year would be awesome.
Okay.
Hold on a second.
Exactly what it is.
Okay,
here it is.
Do you do,
do widen rock cold
Connor all down.
Yo Omer Marrow Jack,
right?
That's the other big fights
at home.
No,
she's January 3rd Brian.
I don't agree with that fight.
Holly Holm fight.
I just don't think that's smart.
I would've gone with a man and Nunez before Holly Holm.
Amanda Nunez look like a bad ass.
Damn McMann.
That's,
that's more dangerous fighter.
If I'm a fighter,
I get it though.
What do you do?
Like you'll all you're doing,
all you're doing is cause when Rhonda leaves,
you need people to know these other girls.
So basically just putting all these marketing dollars into these girls,
they're going to get their ass whooped.
What are you going to do?
You know what I'm saying?
So at least when the leaves were like,
Oh yeah,
that's all he homes.
She finally got her neck snapped off.
Better stand up than Ronda.
Right.
I disagree.
Not to say.
Not really.
I would say too,
as a boxer,
best boxer in the world,
pride,
however,
in the world for girl as a woman,
but like the deal is is like in boxing it's a lot of point fighting.
It's like point karate and so like is there not power in those hands and Rhonda
has it and Holly's been doing a different kind of sport for a long time.
I agree 100% with take.
Like if it was boxing.
Yeah man.
Now we got to fight the best boxer in the world for women.
If Ann Wolfe decides to still not box,
cause an waffle bitches,
she might only be mean.
She might be 40 or whatever the fuck she is.
But if Ann Wolfe decides to run through a training camp,
tell you what man,
that is one check that as a dude,
I would not want to get punched by.
She's ferocious.
Slap a bitch.
I don't care who Ronda fights.
Really.
I just want to see her fight.
I just want to see if I tell him you're not here,
you're not going to be interested in excited to be Holly Holm against Rhonda.
Like I want to see it if you demolish her in a minute.
But what's like pick up Mike Tyson with uh,
Bruce Seldon.
Bruce Seldin Frey Bruno,
uh,
Trevor Berbick eggs.
Oh,
those guys,
at least those guys were world class though.
My man,
and it's true.
Rhonda combativeness Usain Bolt going to the Special Olympics and attract world
class against opposition.
That was it.
Mike Tyson.
You know what I mean?
Mike Tyson made all those guys.
Never,
never really terrified in the ring.
He went right through them all but looks just like Rhonda.
But they were legit worldclass fighter who seldom there were a lot of them were
former world Bruce to
that was legit world class.
You're talking about an Olympian.
They were really good fighters from running.
The real problem with those guys is that they were fighting Tyson.
The real problem with Rhonda is Rhonda is like a Mike Tyson.
She's an elite of the elite girls.
Girls are good.
They're good,
they're good,
they're good.
She's great as it goes better than them out there that are among the best that
this is what we got
the best in.
Uh,
see if you look at,
there's some girls like,
I think Amanda Nunez has real potential.
She has real potential.
Should never be [inaudible] good day.
Yeah,
she's worldclass right.
Claude you get daily is dangerous.
You want to on check worldclass there's a few cyborg steroids are no steroids.
You know,
take away all that controversy.
Just go buy based on her performances for Roche is terrifying.
Worldclass dangerous fighter.
That's for,
what did she say?
Labor Cyborg.
What?
What's going on with her?
But the lady Shit,
Cyborg,
whoever the fuck or manager is,
she's a fire.
That person she used to,
she needs to just lose weight,
get on a scale show.
He and I am.
I make one 35 Rhonda.
That bell is my pitch.
That's it.
I'm not going to try and steal your idea.
What about Misha Tate?
Cyborg catch weight?
Yeah.
Why the fuck me?
She's not screaming for this.
Have no idea.
No.
What happened?
Thinking about that.
Fuck a catch weight.
If that chick wants a fight at one 35 proof,
you can make one 35 jumped all over me.
Yeah.
Cool.
Rousy home and Cyborg Meesha on the same car.
Yes,
because the fans really don't know side.
They really don't know who she don't know and if she goes in there and mops
meets or Tate,
which I don't think she does,
I think she loses him one just saying she could easily lose to Michelle 35
easily.
I think she does one 35 is a different animal for not only that,
it's a different animal now because no ivys the,
Oh,
if you get caught with the IB to your band,
homey or ban two year ban,
if you'd use an ivy to rehydrate,
well,
you did a podcast with the guy.
You have to Wicki.
Nope.
Why you?
How dare all of you.
Why do they get good?
He talked about how you get it.
Was He taught,
he address the fact that is dangerous for the fighters were,
well he said,
this is actually some studies that show that it's more effective to rehydrate
with water,
with drinking it orally.
I have not looked into that and I,
but he said,
he said nothing.
Extreme cases of jail.
He goes,
all athletes are extreme.
that's for the average person who's being hydrated.
Mouth oral is better,
but for extreme cases,
ivs better.
And if you have a doctor's note you can get it.
But
I'm a huge Jeff Novitsky.
It's huge fan.
He's damn,
this dude is legit.
Oh here's a hundred people are fuck.
Oh he busted Lance Armstrong.
He busted while sort of busted Barry bonds because Barry Bonds Guy,
that was one thing we found out after the podcast.
He's,
he was recently acquitted on all charges.
Like they didn't catch Barry on anything.
Yeah.
They,
it's all like,
they wasted all that money.
He was making it out.
Like it's some big message they were sending to the children.
And I was like,
all right,
whatever would all that.
It's like,
let's not think about kids.
We're talking about adult professional athletes.
Fuck Barry bonds over.
Well,
what they were doing was they were trying to prosecute with what they do is they
have a mandate.
Someone tells them to prosecute and they have to prosecute on what's up with
that girl's shorts.
By the way,
on the left,
it was like a combination of like Thai shorts,
short shorts.
He's got something under him,
Joe.
But under wearing booty shorts under those,
what I never understood was why congress cared about steroids.
It's redacted.
Never made a tremendous waste of money.
Tax payers,
more athletes in the Wicki was very,
uh,
well that's the funniest thing about the congressional thing was listening to
Joe Biden talk about how back when he was an athlete,
you know,
and I always wondered if a guy was on some something.
I'm sure Joe,
my God,
given talent,
like he's so close.
Joe Biden's disgusting mention steroids in a state of the union.
People always forget that Joe Biden's a plagiarist by the way.
They forget the Joe Biden we used to do was show bite on his middle school a
exam,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
not just that you plagiarized Kennedy's speeches when he's running for president
back in [inaudible] 88 we were,
when we were at stitches Comedy Club in Boston,
we should do it Joe Biden night in the eighties,
where comics would go up.
Like I would do your material.
You would do my material.
We do each other shit.
It's called Joe Biden.
How does someone like that?
And someone like Hillary Clinton will not forget about the email stuff,
but all the stuff she did with Bill Clinton with that doubt.
Whitewater style.
Yeah.
Like terrifying.
All that stuff.
That why,
why do you,
how would they still like candidates to read the book?
The strain on the death of Vince Foster,
Vince foster was one of the people that was involved in the Whitewater scandal.
Jesus on himself,
uh,
in,
in a park.
Okay.
Had his,
the gun still in his hand,
which never fucking happens.
Every,
every single expert will tell you when you shoot yourself in the head,
your body goes by and that gun goes flying.
He's still got the gun in his hand,
no blood at the scene of the crime.
His body had been mulling this hundred percent his body had been moved to spare
seats.
That ain't even a conspiracy gangster.
Like that's what gangsters do.
They don't want to just kill a body and have them disappear.
They want to leave a message.
You're going to try to bust us.
We're coming up to you.
Keep the shit out of court or your,
you and your family are dead.
Makes Sense.
Any bravos and just doing it to fuck we garrison beer conspiracy.
That's all the matters.
Kind.
Keep the weeds under wraps,
Jamie,
Hillary Clinton and here we go.
The candidates for the presidency of the United States.
How Much Eddie Bravo loves,
loves conspiracy.
These quills girls in full guard and he's not even talking about Jujitsu.
Doesn't give a fuck.
She went up to Michigan draw,
shut the fuck up.
Pissed cause I didn't get that.
I don't see.
I don't see why after that Ben Saunders,
fine.
Everybody's not doing that.
Well,
you know what?
I got a message today.
It was really interested in the Jiu Jitsu coaches of the MMA camps.
They decide and they decide what they're going to train it.
What was the point of sale if they don't make that decision to stick that into
training.
Let's work a little bit on this.
Uh,
elbows from Michigan troll healers.
They got done.
We just try and do here.
She's trying to wrap her leg and sticker her foot underneath the armpit of
Latino who is on the bottom or on the top.
Dude,
I wish she gave up on it,
but look to keep,
oh damn.
Fleas or legs pulled ahead.
She needs to control that and she got caught.
She's got a friend grabbed the head at this point.
Look at Latino,
thinks she's safe by tucking her man.
That shit doesn't work.
Especially like this.
Total.
You get the squeeze,
he'll get the squeeze notes.
I wish in between rounds highlights what already happened.
Oh Wow.
Nice.
Nicest Cape.
I wish they'd show the previous fights.
Quick highlight turtles,
a nasty striker man.
She's got good technique.
You see the way she moves very,
very loose and relax.
Good.
Like like mu variation or speed.
She counters as well too.
She just keeps her head down.
Chin down.
Just
I think and I'm beginning to listen to nick curse on about this.
I think a giant part of what holds fighters bag is strength and conditioning I
think.
What do you mean?
I used to think that it's more important to work on skills than anything and I
think up to a certain point it is,
but now I think what holds people back is like like Latino right now I see a
slower fighter.
Then I saw in the first round we'll see.
I see.
Like some significant slowing and like she's having a hard time executing.
I agree.
It depends on your skill level.
Yes.
It depends on the skill level.
You should focus more on strength conditioning,
get in shape so we can show your skills for three rounds,
two minutes in the first minute,
two minutes of a fight.
It's all about your skills,
but then as fights go on,
it's all about how much conditioning do you have in the tank to use those skills
and nerve endings are all about how quickly you can recover and can your body
recover multiple times.
Yup.
And you think at an elite level they would be able to go 25 minutes can seem
gas.
They seem a little,
well,
there's slower,
slower for sure,
but that's the like dos Anjos um,
when we saw dos Anjos fight pedis,
that motherfucker kept that same pace for five rounds.
He was guns ablaze and for five rounds we get Demetrius Johnson and gets all the
bag of teen off.
Ali Bag off was on e worked that motherfucker up.
Tj Dillashaw same thing.
Exactly.
Same thing.
You think what he did Atlantic on Borow Tj Dillashaw mighty mouse would happen.
Can't happen.
Big great fight.
And why it's only 20 towns about it.
Mighty mouse is fought one 35.
He fucked Dominique's too.
He lost to Dominick Cruz.
Yep.
I think that Tj Dillashaw is one of the best pound for pound fighters in the
world.
I think these with Hanan.
Barao was
like a wake up call to everybody.
Yeah,
he beat the fucking shit out of hand and next for me.
He beat the fucking shit out of him.
Like he owned him from the moment.
It wasn't even a fight.
It wasn't a fight.
It was a clinic.
Dominick Cruz,
Cruz need doesn't fall off.
Everything is knee like race.
He breaks his hands all the time so he can't count on that
huge fight.
And Dominick is natural.
He's all natural and he's in his thirties you know and at 135 pounds
traditionally,
especially in boxing,
once you hit the one,
the thirties tough NFL running back speed rely on speed and reflexes more than
anybody because they're so fast like mighty mouse and Dodson.
Holy Shit.
That's going to be a bowler.
That fight's going to be
legit threat though.
He's a legit threat.
Dotson can knock out anybody.
He knocked out Tj people don't forget about that on the ultimate fighter.
Fuck yeah he did.
He beat the shit out of Tj.
He did different Tj for sure.
Totally different tea.
Tea.
There's Tj pre and post bang.
True and pre pre cause suggestions.
Cause no one loves fighting more than us.
Right.
But that a fricking Datsun um,
John Dotson verse Johnson fights.
It's a tough sell man.
Like I'm not like Ooh I can't fucking wait to see them throw down.
It's different.
And those guys are more talented than any cause you're a cyclist.
You might be right.
Hey me and the entire world then a problem cause he's not selling paper view.
We've got another round.
Are his shows among the worst sizes.
Those just new like real bad.
Not Good.
It's tough man.
He's those talents.
Again in the UFC it's just people,
it's hard for you to jump on board on a small guy like he got,
he got denied access to the club.
He's the fricking multiple time world champion in the UFC.
They thought he was 15 at a height limit.
I don't know.
There's just a lot of people that didn't know who he was.
You know those lines in Vegas.
Nobody gets in those phones.
They recognize him.
Yeah.
They didn't recognize him.
Those lines of bummer man.
Cause he's so talented.
He needs a couple more good fights like Dodson.
He needs an arch rival.
Can you tell when you're talking shit,
the whole gets a Conor Mcgregor won 25 he never sinned.
Felder.
Holy Shit fight or I'm a huge fan of that dude.
He's opposed.
Fuck.
He's fun to watch.
Throws strikes from everyone,
especially after that bar,
but it was a fight.
God,
Oh she got,
she got it.
The fact that he didn't he,
he went the distance with them.
Oh yeah.
Losses with them and Barboza was kicking the shit and switch,
kick that switch keys.
The fastest switchgear guy I've ever seen ever in my life,
ever.
Ever,
Remember Jamie Varner was talking about how before and he beat him,
but before that he was the most scared he's ever been before a fight.
Yeah.
That's a scary Barboza.
Joe Silva calls you and said you want Barboza.
There's a couple of guys where you get that call.
You're like,
yeah,
I guess I'll think about that.
Terry.
Adam,
fight without wheel kick
to the head first wheel kick,
k on the opposite.
You got to fight them next.
Yeah.
Jails,
his kicks.
He's the only guy I've ever stopped to fighters with leg kicks.
He's nasty.
Mike Lulo and fail Oliveira both with leg kicks.
I'm not going to wrap the guy out,
but super high level guy,
super high level guy.
My manager goes,
Brendan,
I want you in on this call.
This is the best part of my job.
Watch this broke.
Just got this huge fight.
Announced me six and just Silva.
Watch this.
We're in a hotel.
Calls him on speed dial.
He goes,
my man got to fight for you.
Who said this?
Alexandra Gustafson September or whatever and he's all white and the guy goes,
ah shit.
Really?
He goes,
yeah man.
AH,
fuck.
Well let's get this paper.
Hangs up the phone.
My managers all off.
Fuck man,
I don't want your boy's going to lose for sure.
Ah Fuck.
How do I solve that?
Can't tell you man.
I'm not going to sell the guy out.
Big Long Tall motherfucker.
And how long ago was this?
It was TJ before they weight classes is Tj Dillashaw.
It was so funny,
man.
In Japan.
He was so heartbroken.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
When you,
that's the thing about the UFC and MMA in general,
like there's a lot of fighters that they jump into the UFC and they are starting
to have some success.
Well,
there's a very short climb until you're in worldclass territory and if you beat
one of those motherfuckers off to the races a year,
you shop style,
urine,
be shopstyle Chris touch your shirt and they're like,
oh cool.
Here's Gonzaga.
I was like,
holy fuck man.
Easy Bro.
I fights.
Is that Brad?
What was that?
Stanley Grad.
Dallas.
Tampa.
He's,
excuse me,
Susan affliction.
Sure.
Anything.
Boy Damn it.
It's about ice and there's a black puck,
I think they call us.
You got to get it in the net and when they do live,
when you see a loss.
This is a dope CA's amazing.
No,
no.
Tony.
Tony Sims is from Denver.
He's older.
He's been boxing since he was like six.
He got in the UFC super late,
man.
This is second short fight in a row.
I'm telling you,
this kid is a monster.
Tough fight.
Familiar.
Either way.
Hey,
give me one of them beers there,
Mr. Keller.
Yeah,
sure.
Mine a little wobbly.
Pop County.
You'll hear me going.
Well Uva,
I'm excited about this main event,
man.
We got the bed on the main event or what bro?
You are.
No,
that's illegal.
we did co main event.
I got Neil magna.
You got your Silva.
Remember honey,
Dick,
me man.
Doesn't matter.
Hold on now you people listening to this don't know what we're talking about
because we are,
we had this discussion before the podcast,
but Brennan Shab sent me a photo and a,
I'm going to take this photo and I'm going to um,
uh,
I'll,
I'll show it to you guys,
but this is the,
the difference.
You could find this photo online.
This is the difference between Eric Silva a while ago and Eric Sylvan.
Now a fan sent that to me
should be banned.
Look at the photo on the top.
That's him now lead the photo in the bottle.
I got honey.
Dick,
can I see this?
Is this?
Oh God,
no,
that was great.
That was good reaction and a laptop.
I'm thinking about getting a new laptop and I mean,
I'm really thinking,
oh no,
that's $1,500.
Would you say Jamie picture?
Anyway,
so the suggestion is that it's possible that Eric silver may or may not have
been.
Oh,
it looks like I got lucky here.
Ooh,
good Lord.
What a difference.
It only got on my screen.
God,
I all I know is I'm getting on the old DRT.
They tell you,
you're still not going to look like no.
I want to have his hair.
I'll tell you that I'm already 80.
You should have done it in the sec guys.
I've been taken,
um,
create a team.
That's why it looked thicker.
He has been taking creatine.
Yup.
Well that stuff works.
It does.
It makes your face fat does add water weight in my face.
Tell him thank you.
It's my face.
Five pounds of face.
That is a remarkable difference.
I guess he's just not working out as hard.
Um,
um,
that's it for sure.
Changes is eating more fatty foods.
Maybe more outside you or some shit.
The more I say,
either way,
Eddie can't back out now.
Honey.
Dick Neil,
Mag d,
he took the fight on two weeks notice,
decided if I think Eddie is allowed the back off before the fight actually
starts.
You know what I'm asking you guys exchanged money,
even with your steroids.
I'm going to do it.
We're going hunting.
I'm going to go with her honey decor.
Notice how he's hunted or sterilized.
I'm the dealer,
so
we'll do it.
It's all how you feel,
but you don't sign it.
I,
I actually,
uh,
you know Eric Sheila was the favorite.
Yeah,
but he looks soft now
and that's because he's still a cutie pie.
You already had a problem with cardio,
right?
Yes.
He's a module at first round.
He's a ferocious guy and he'd be expends a lot of energy.
And when you fight a guy like Matt Brown that she does not recommend,
who would you take?
If you had to bet the last thing you want to do is be drained.
If you had to bet,
who did you take?
Right?
Magni.
I like magnet in that fight because I think magna is more consistent and Maggie
has great endurance and Maggie's only problem that he's shown inside the octagon
of all is dealing with Damien.
Motherfucker beat down south director.
He's a constructor that's like you're a chained up sheep.
Matt and his fucking giant anacondas wrapping its body at reunion squeezing as
well.
Who Do you have in the main event?
Eddie?
I had a Holloway but he didn't want to like is a beast.
Okay,
I disagree.
I got all of era.
You got $1,000 yeah,
I do have $1,000 why don't you bet Brian Kelly wealthy?
I'll take the bad just to make the podcast more excited.
I don't want to take $1,000 from a good friend,
but I'll bet you 20 bucks so I could win.
All right.
What are we betting?
Why can't ours?
Well,
how about we get out of here?
Yeah,
let's do dinner.
That's a good call.
I got to make sure I can do that.
We'll go get some state.
We've got to make sure isn't that cross?
We're married.
We have kids that this is bullshit.
We're not even masters of our own domain.
It's true.
I got to see if I got to see if I can do what I want to do.
I know because my boss,
I have to check in with the boss.
She's so awesome.
She lets me do everything.
So yeah,
no,
I get that.
Yeah,
we're all night except having dinner on Sundays.
You kind of got to,
I understand.
Put it in your time.
All right,
so we can make it 20 bucks now we'll go to dinner.
Um,
all right.
I got back.
I got bullied into dinner.
I have to pay now,
but don't get me wrong.
Max Holloway can win and I would not be,
she's the favorite.
I wouldn't be so Izzy.
He's the favorite.
What am I?
Who am I t I disagree with.
It's a close fight.
I think it's a close fight.
I,
this is,
this is my take on it.
I think that all Avera is a little more tactical,
both standing up and on the ground that are on the ground.
I agree.
I'll switch it up.
You want.
I'll take all of her events standing on a switch up the bet.
Switch it up.
Double or nothing.
I'll forget about the Eric Silva.
Well,
that one's fine.
let's see how the variable doesn't.
All of air like kinda wouldn't he be kind of flubby too?
What do you mean flubby?
Yeah.
Oliveira no,
wait.
What's flubby basically these are not gonna look the same.
You're saying?
Yes.
Nah,
he's a really skinny guy.
He's thin.
Yeah.
He's,
it doesn't look like a real void right at all.
He actually dropped down from 55 to 45 read it.
Yeah.
I don't think he's a steroid use.
You want to switch it up to take Holloway?
Well,
let's,
let's see how old the Neil back the fight.
We'll do double or nothing and not take stick with Holloway is before we,
before I ask you this way,
he wanted to ask you this question before I asked you this question.
Let's think about the possibility of the MMA media out of proportion because
they owe TMZ.
What?
What it is TMZ now,
right?
[inaudible] we had seven different articles,
dude stone talking shit.
I snapshot centered.
A Rhogam went,
oh shit.
I said,
fuck.
Now here's the question.
Percentage of the Brazilian Jujitsu fighters or Brazilian MMA fighters you think
are on steroids.
If you had to guess free thing,
we're not face
to start installing.
You know what?
I don't want to just single out Brazilians.
I think a majority of the guys are a majority.
A lot of the Brazilians,
so you think it's 90% of all the MMA fighters are on steroids,
the correct Brazilians do you think are not on steroids?
Wow,
that's a good question.
Which ones are not Nogueira for sure,
right?
Noguera he's not.
Why?
I said why do you look that you've seen of ghost little nug.
That's not dead.
He gets me in trouble,
man
thing last time it wasn't me
so bad.
No,
Sarah sat feels really,
really bad for that.
I understand the thing about it or hear it on steroids.
The understated thing about the steroids is the mental aspect.
Like these fighters aren't coming out as aggressive like silver as a destroyer
normally,
but let's say he was on tier.
What's it going to be now?
Is he going to be a little more passive?
It's not just the body,
it's the line.
He will rely on that test doc whenever it came from,
from some pride.
Right.
And everybody would like pride is the killers were like,
that's the better show than the UFC athletes.
What they all came and got beat up by,
by guys that weren't top tier guys in the UFC.
Every one of those pride athletes.
True.
And that's all,
that's all due to drugs.
And that's not abilities or uh,
or strength even I think,
I think it's exactly what Aubrey is saying.
It's there.
They're like,
who am I without?
This cannot only that,
these guys weren't doing it properly.
I'm sure they didn't take enough time to recover and get their natural test
level.
So they're probably compromised.
So not only would they not on steroids,
they are compromised.
Because when you look at some of those guys in pride,
we don't need to name names,
we don't need to name names.
But when they came over,
they looked physically different.
They look physically different.
You know,
I mean,
look at Cro cop.
Here's a perfect advantage example.
Cro Cop was a god damn destroyer.
I mean you look at some of the,
the,
the fights that he had,
the wear and tear,
there's a lot going on but he just was a different guy.
When you can't a look at the amount of high kicks he through before and after
and it's just he wasn't aggressive enough when he came back.
It wasn't this or that left kick all the time.
It was just like still
care about steroids.
One FC.
Yeah.
They want you on them.
They will for sure.
When I've seen it helps soccer kicks to the face.
Steroids.
Steroids are nice about it.
That fucked me up.
When is,
when is Roger Fighting coming up soon?
I think like September 1st maybe he looks good in training.
Let's look at some of the videos of him.
Any paths I hung out with him and Thailand as a coach.
That was a trip he had fun with man.
Right when I got the time,
when I landed,
the thing that I tripped out on the most,
everybody,
I'm going to tax you.
And we were like getting driven to tie your Muay Thai and everybody's on little
scooters,
like four,
four people per scoot.
Her kids,
they're holding their kids and everyone's riding scooters.
I thought how insane and scary is this?
I ended up at,
Rodger were at this house a couple nights later,
we're a hanging out chillin and there's like four of us.
And they said,
let's go to the party town down the street.
You know,
it's like 45 minutes away.
And I'm like,
okay,
let's go.
And uh,
they all have like,
how are we getting there?
Like,
oh,
we're going on scooters.
So I drove a Roger where's the,
drove me in a scooter and I'm sitting behind him in a scooter or 45 minutes for
the hills and say,
come on Tony.
Since starting right now,
all ball merciay in sims powerful 43 seconds.
Right now I lay Olivier football,
football,
know ca is friends with the guys at Joe Beef and Montreal.
That restaurant that we always eat at.
He's a great guy.
He's got that horse meat in him.
He's got like literally they eat horse meat.
I didn't want any dude shut telling you Tony Sims.
Boxing is fucking
filthy.
They Lulu comes in in [inaudible] prime.
I'm doing French media here.
Phones on.
So you hear how retarded you.
So yeah,
but I'm doing for now where I'm helping the French people.
All bomb.
Rca is good on the ground meat you can eat,
they can get you the similar effects to steroids.
No hope you've talked to a rhino meet bear bag.
Those rumors,
Asians will pick up on it and there'll be no licensed.
It's either gotta be something like a shit load of rock bottom testicle that
they can ban you.
Oh you can't eat moose anymore cause it turns out and loose.
Shrinks your balls.
Some stuff that is IGF one in it,
you know that you can get but like really good deer antler.
We'll have IGF one in it.
How about you?
There's a guy.
How's it are stuffed with steroids?
Does
test positive.
Did that thing with the antlers.
There's a guy who ran an elk farm up in Alberta and he got an elk farm just for
the deer antler.
Shit.
It would take the velvet velvet and the velvet and the velvet as IGF one.
You spray it in your mouth and it and it gives you a benefit like similar to
taking growth hormone.
The market dried up like instantaneously somehow or another,
I don't know what it was,
whether it became too easy to get real growth hormone or people just stop using
it.
I don't know what the fuck happened,
but this guy is stuck with a bunch of elk on this land.
Every now and then he wanders out there and shoots one in,
eats it,
spend 1 million bucks.
It's got to be fenced in elk.
Yeah,
it's come as the fish in this position.
Igf One isn't legal anyways,
and so like what's the point?
You know it's illegal to take that.
If you take that elk deer Antler,
shit,
you can test.
The trick is is that if you test it and show that it has IGF one,
then it's not illegal.
So you have to do it untested and then you don't know whether it's got it in
there or not.
So it's,
it's like this weird can you mean I'm confused?
Well,
you're not really allowed to sell IGF one like over the counter,
right.
So if you standardize the elk antler to make sure that it has IGF one,
then it's not legal as far as I understand when I,
when I looked into it.
So even though it's still just a natural product that contains IGF one,
so it's illegal no matter what cell is a dietary supplement.
I mean you could sell it but not as a dietary supplement.
It would be illegal,
but you wouldn't test for it.
So you could sell the Antler,
but you don't test for it.
And then,
but then the consumer doesn't know if it's bullshit,
I just got to sell it.
You're there.
Like the velvet velvet is they grow.
They don't only happens when they grow unless you have a female that grows
antlers,
which is very rare and sometimes they stay in velvet.
How though?
How did they figure?
There's IGF one in the antlers.
What kind of crazy fun figured that out?
I don't know.
Some fucking country acts swinging redneck was just eating antler and just shred
it.
Just Dick.
Just nice
to me feel better.
I do have his insulin growth factor one.
Is that what that is,
isn't it?
What HTA.
Is that what hh converts to in the body?
Is that correct or no?
I do a little research or go deeper on that and I'm not sure,
but either way I need it.
A lot of guys were taking that though.
A lot of football players are taking a football book.
Deer antler.
Yeah.
He's real popular stuff.
I know a tennis pro does it and I was like,
well,
I don't know.
What'd he say?
He swears by it.
He plays,
he can play all day.
I mean he's,
did they test in 10 he swears by Goji berries and deer antler.
Goji Berries,
very high in antioxidants.
Do they test the tennis
tour?
Sure.
Yeah,
definitely.
That's why,
uh,
the,
tried to test it was Venus or Serena for sure.
She ran into her fucking safe.
She had a safe house,
safe room in her house in case her house got home,
invaded Sharan tour,
uh,
her safe room and called the cops on the fucking drug testers.
Really?
Cause she didn't want to get tested.
Dude.
After talking to know Wicki and talking to the two guys that I've talked to,
um,
uh,
what's his face from balco,
Victor Conte and Debicki.
I am convinced that there's just a giant percentage of professional athletes
that are on steroids and certainly you needed to talk to them to figure that
out.
You really need to like find out what the methods are.
You know,
they have testosterone now that they're making with animals no longer with yams.
So now the carbon isotope tasks that they used to catch people that were taking
plant based testosterone,
it doesn't work anymore.
So now you get,
you know,
this guy's going to be on this animal base testosterone.
So explain to me how they get,
I mean,
I can't believe they get testosterone from yams.
This is strange.
No idea.
You should probably pull out your phone and Google it and explainers dosing now,
right?
Yeah.
Boy was talking about doing four hour doses.
The dose,
it only stays in your system for four hours.
Yeah.
That's like the Alex Rodriguez Shit.
He was taking gummy bears,
testosterone,
gummy bears.
It's not going to be long till they can clone your pituitary and it would just
have it pumping out your own hormones.
Yeah,
right.
God wants some more from my spare pituitary over there.
Hopefully we'll get a second.
Pituitary gland stalled her hair for sure.
Watch your head get wider.
Shut up.
Just put one in the Tate just right in the face and the tank.
Yeah,
you get your spleen removed.
Replaced it with a pituitary gland.
Did he say anything about the longterm effects?
It doesn't seem like there's any evidence that like,
like microdosing testosterone is bad for you while your body has testosterone in
it.
It's not a foreign substance.
Your body knows what to do with it.
The problem with things that your body doesn't know what to do with his
toxicity.
Liver toxicity,
you know,
there's,
there's a lot of issues with all sorts of different substances like EPO that
caused strokes,
unnatural things like when you take an EPO,
your body's producing way more fucking red blood cells and it's supposed to,
what your bloods like sludge,
all sorts of issues with that.
But testosterone he bought,
he knows what to do with it.
It's in there naturally.
He,
although they're talking about those,
uh,
the Baikal,
the bike riders wake up in the middle of the night cause their
blood so thick.
They told you this?
Yeah.
They would wake up and ride their bike in the middle of the night.
That's a buddy of ours go crazy because they had to get rid of the blood cells
or what do you mean?
Yeah,
what do you want?
So thick it blood so thick.
You have to wear yourself out and you have to,
you have to do workouts and drink a lot of water in the middle of the night.
They would set their alarms.
They get up every few hours and work out.
I heard a heart surgeon talk about one thing you can do.
There are some studies that suggest that giving blood once a year actually is
the best thing you can do to avoid stroke.
Um,
and women have,
they think have less stroke and less heart disease.
It might be because they bleed once a month.
So what happens is you,
I guess your blood actually literally gets thinner.
Um,
now some rationale for leaches back in the day nobody was talking about was
really fascinating because you know what you can do to increase your,
I guess lower your cholesterol and especially in give blood.
I,
God damn it back some studies MTM,
it Tony about mercy is,
yeah,
he's looks very strong,
very strong.
Haufle Easter bowling in the corner there.
Yeah.
Elliot Christian L.
Yeah,
they're just having a heart disease.
You having a hard time keeping this guy off of them all over that he wants
nothing in the standup game with them.
He just pin them is and taking them down.
Well smart because smart.
That's smart though.
There's my boyfriend Krishna.
It's going to be weird when they come up with all these fucking genetic
manipulations that they're working on right now.
They think China's already got myostatin inhibitors in place for their athletes.
CISA,
smancy.
Yeah,
and the thing,
they're already experimenting on it.
They got someone locked up in a mountain somewhere and they got some fucking
dude who's a triple muscle and was going to live to be 190 that's awesome.
Awesome.
By the way,
that's what,
that's what happened to those mice when they ran those tests on those miles tat
and inhibitors in mice,
the mice became superhuman or super mice.
They've got all this muscle on them and they live longer and they don't
degenerate.
Wow.
There was this like double must sign me up right now.
That'd be,
I'd get rid of it at the time where we take sims,
turn around,
look at this.
He's about to get taken down again,
but how about tell my why.
How about wider,
little wider there fell a little wider with that stands please.
There'll be a time when we choose bodies like cars.
That's going to be a sarcoma insert consciousness into whatever body.
Every girl is going to look the same.
There's going to be designer cars.
That was all we switch it up though.
You know,
they'll come out with a new model and that'll be,
how else can you do?
How long realistically,
how long?
500 years where they could pull your consciousness now a consciousness out and
put it into Kate's body.
How long?
500 years.
Well,
we're going to be able to have chips less than that.
We're going to be able to have chips and you're going to be able to live your
life and then give me a chip at the of the day and like,
what'd you do today?
You like,
watch it,
do it.
Plugging into May and I'll live the life of Eddie Bravo for a day.
I'm like,
Bro,
check out this chick I hooked up with play this.
I should have.
Watch it.
Sell your dreams.
You know what I mean?
Record your dreams.
Sound Bull.
Yeah.
There's going to be a lot of weird shit going on in the next hundred,
200 years.
There's one thing though,
that novelty of like being able to choose your body or whatever it is.
It's like one of the things I think that people appreciate it.
It's like it's his hard work,
his people married and what it is and like if there's no merit to it,
what's the value of it?
Our way forging character and it's a spiritual crisis.
I mean it's a thing because like outside of the physical realm,
there's a whole nother,
there's a whole entire other conversation to have with that and like at what
time do we get tired of the novelty for something with substance,
right.
Our,
our entire paradigm is built on that,
on struggle and the parents
come from who you are though.
That's not your body.
Right?
If you could be a 12 year old boy right now,
would you be,
what of you identify as a 12 year old boy?
Can you still get into Chucky cheese?
You can identify as anybody now that you can identify as black.
They caught a second guy pretending to be black.
Did you see that guy who identified as being an amputee and thought that's what
he was and then he cut off his arms cause it's his hand.
Didn't feel normal to them.
I did see that.
Yeah,
no,
I saw it.
It's called mental illness.
It's called so,
so flies in the face of all this stuff about like,
oh,
we're all born equal.
No we're not.
There's some different shit.
It's stupid.
It's stupid to say that we're born equal.
It's,
it's nonsense.
No,
we don't all start at the same starting line gestures,
the social construct man to social construct.
It's not,
no,
no.
We're all different as fuck.
There's a broad spectrum of human beings and some of us have hands and some of
us,
a lot of it's meant don't want hand.
Well,
a lot of it,
like the guy,
the amputee,
you're talking about,
a lot of it's,
you know,
mental disease,
right?
So what do you do with those guys?
Like here's the thing I was talking with Brian.
How about child molesters?
You're mentally fucked up,
man.
The subway guy,
you're going to get a foot long son.
You need a foot long now in jail.
Police don't say that again Jerry.
There was a cover of Mark Daily News.
Was it really?
Yes.
Yeah,
it was what?
The cover of New York Daily News expect a foot long in jail.
Um,
but I think he's super screwed.
He super screwed.
But there was an article recently that was talking about people that have a
natural
inclination towards pedophilia and that it's something that is hardwired into
their brain.
And then they were trying to make this argument along those same lines as
someone bring transgender.
And I was like,
Whoa,
this is a fucking very tricky argument because if you start giving people the
green light to be pedophiles in any way,
shape or form,
there's a lot of people gonna jump on that.
It's not,
what's not the debate.
I'm not saying it's a debate,
I'm talking about the science behind it.
Using it raises questions that they're transgender.
Either
it's a social issue,
right?
There's no science where people saying people are absolutely born a woman
trapped in a man's body.
But socially we were all accepting.
The bigger question becomes this.
If you can,
if you can prove that it's neurological,
then what classifies as his disability.
And now we all agree we don't want those people in your children.
But the question becomes two,
two falls,
all of us before punishment,
the most important thing is that they don't molest children.
That's what we want to stop them from doing.
So the question becomes,
do you give them safe haven to talk about it?
Go get help,
figure out how to cure it,
you know,
whatever.
I trust them,
trust them deeply.
You have to trust them deeply to not do anything about it.
Not to act on their urges.
Trusting a guy who lives in an island of hot chicks and not fuck Nah,
you keep them very far away from CIC children at this point.
That may change.
I mean,
yeah,
but you're,
so you're going to take them to jail to have a certain gene or are you going to
wait until they act?
That's the question.
So,
so,
so most important is if they do find it neurological,
maybe there's a way to cure that or,
or,
or block the gene eventually.
But for that,
I don't think it's a genetic thing.
Well,
what they find is it might very well be most pedophiles of in a strange way are
lefthanded.
Why we don't know,
but,
but for the most part there is a lot of evidence that suggests it could be
neurologic.
It's not who you are.
Maybe in some cases,
you know there's,
there's a lot of different ways as we learn more about brain science,
it's did you just finding more and more that sometimes this is a form of quote
unquote brain damage or mental illness or whatever.
It doesn't.
The brain doesn't come out perfect every time.
No sims is on top here.
Atlanta,
it's a fucking hammers man.
These are,
these are legit shot.
He hits hard man.
He hits fucking hard in close quarters.
That's one thing about strikers.
You see that there's a big difference in what they can generate,
the amount of power they can at short distances with a,
with ground and pound.
You see that with cro cop in that Gonzaga file,
those elbows inside the guard bits.
Because Cro cop is a legit striker.
And you're seeing this here with sims.
He's close quarters.
Fucking merciay up.
You said Tony Ferguson or little John Dodson?
Man there generate power in like inches and make it count.
Oh,
speaking of which Ferguson's gonna Fight Khabib.
That's a fight.
That is a motherfucker muck on off in Ferguson is a fuck.
When is that?
I don't know.
Do not know,
but I love it.
I love it.
But that's a great,
especially when you see what Ferguson has been fucking doing it people lately.
Well it's,
to me it's just see negative word off because he's been hurt for Madoff.
They can.
You say,
what did you call me
be heartbeat and never coming off.
It's gonna be,
it's just to see him cause he had so much time off and his knees jacked.
It's a tough fight.
I don't,
I don't think he's needs 100% I don't think it can be.
That's a tough
boy.
Oh boy.
Eddie as he got it.
Eddie.
Nope.
He's trying it seem to be struggling
sideways here.
Triangle.
Come on.
It's right.
You don't want a guy goes against a guy who's just better than him.
At Jujitsu,
there's a certain amount of like recognition that the guys better and you don't
try for certain shit.
You get big brother to a little bit.
Yeah.
Almost too much respect.
But then like you go for a a Saab and you're like,
fuck,
I'm not really going to get this.
You don't believe in it.
Now,
ultimate fighter,
September 9th Aldo and my boy,
Uriah Faber,
Gregor Mcgregor,
McGregor rather.
I don't know about the ultimate fighter format.
I Dunno about that format.
Will they're banking on Eikon or bringing the views now,
right?
It's like they're doing whatever they can to get the views back.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
You just got to switch it up.
If I was Connor,
I wouldn't be into doing it.
Me Neither.
But does that mean to you?
Hurts his brand?
That means he's going to fight.
No,
no.
Possibly happen.
It could turn it.
Listen,
let me tell you something right now.
If all though gets hurt again,
they easily could have that fight.
They easily could have Uriah faber versus Connor just supervising easily,
easily.
It's a great backup for sure.
Don't get through,
especially if during the show if they can some on other generate some
respectable ratings.
How has all the doing do they may know.
Who knows?
Hopefully good things going to get hurt again.
It could easily get hurt again.
Just pulled out for multiple fights and there's,
you know,
depending on what is actually going on when it comes to pds over there,
who knows?
Who knows?
I mean there's so much speculation is coach had a presscamp weeks.
I know about pds and we will Brennan,
we would be,
no,
but he's a British ship.
Washed his mouth out.
Yeah.
Hey guys.
Brandon likes Brazilians.
Take it easy.
We're not insulting.
That's not obvious.
You're doing shit at all.
Well,
there's,
there's without a doubt a certain amount of people that have been on the ped
side.
I think it's a legit for focus of discussion.
I just do.
I'm not going to not talk about it.
I'm not going to not talk about it as a speculation.
It's legit.
And especially after talking to Novitsky and talking to many,
many,
many fighters and managers,
the trainers,
they work.
Of course they work.
Yeah.
And here's the other thing,
well 10 Kennedy said to you,
he's like,
if you,
you've been tested.
I haven't been tested.
You know that like everyone is being tested.
Everyone's being tested.
Really.
He's like,
who's been tested?
Yeah.
Tim got,
I think he got tested yesterday.
The day before.
Was that some of the UFC,
it wasn't that UFC really who tested him because Tim had pissed bottles up and
it was like get,
but that was no cause he,
he put that out and goes,
UFC still hasn't test me.
He goes,
I'm in touch.
And now I think at the military,
test them all the time and he goes to the UFC,
still hasn't tested me.
Jesus Christ.
And the question is too is like not even who's currently on steroids,
but who's on,
who's on the live roster that's moving.
That has been,
that's like,
I mean there's guys that are cycling in and out all that all the time and really
I think the question Eddie asked,
but like who's not,
how many guys aren't is like who's never done that?
That's that signed under that contract that gets that check from the EOC.
Yeah.
That was a weird moment.
And the Anderson Silva press conference where they said,
is this the first time you've ever been tested at a competition?
And he goes,
yes.
And I'm like,
fuck.
The one time they pop you,
the only time
you've ever been tested at a competition and they pop you,
but did any take by Agra or something?
Legitly that's what he says is more than one story.
Bas Rutten was going over it and he said he changed his story three times.
Are you test positive?
Is that what happens here?
Let's not talk over each other.
Elevate testosterone.
We did.
Jagger does,
no,
it has nothing to do with it.
What did you say?
Hold on.
But viagara ad is a performance enhancing drug and it is illegal because vi
Viagara actually does enhance your body.
It's like a very extreme version of nitric oxide is a dilator and blood flow.
Right.
So really does benefit you in an endurance.
Wow.
Yeah.
Endurance Athletes Take Viagra.
Blood vessels.
I've,
I've trained on it before I did a Jujitsu,
I took a Cialis.
And did you just,
you just see what it was like?
Yeah,
I'd get it benefits you,
but no more so than shrimp tech.
Mushroom.
[inaudible]
the 10th planet secret.
You don't get hard unless you're [inaudible].
You just say,
is that shut up?
Nope.
That's my Dick.
Still.
Cops are brutal man.
And what could you do if you've got the guys back with their hooks in?
Just find the guy,
be immersive.
Stare at it until he's done.
Press down on this paint.
Just tap right.
Yep.
Now Tab.
But don't be silly.
Don't be in polite.
Just realize that there's a pecking order and he's the alpha.
It's amazing to me that those metal cups are not illegal in the UFC.
To train with guys with a cups on is a drag and that's a for sure because they
put it in you cause it hurts.
You mean
fulcrum point for armbars break people's arms with it guys on top of half guard
and grinding like that.
That's a thing,
man,
that's a not calm,
you know north south the session.
Oh you remember Amir [inaudible] Amir,
right?
I've already mounted me once and he put the grape vines entity had a go,
what the fuck is that?
He goes,
this is a Thai Cup pro steel tie cup.
I go,
what the fuck man?
He was like,
no,
it was mounding me.
He was pressing it down on my back in the day.
Those were the only guys you when you were training and there's a new guy,
they're always kickboxers are boxers that came in that wanted to try to ditch
it.
Those were the only guys that work up.
There was never really grappling dude.
Like I never really knew Jujitsu guys that would wear cops,
something like now,
but back then it was like guys that came in from kickbox.
The way I train is I put shorts on,
I get my shoes on and I put my cup on and that's the same way they would come
onto the match.
Well,
I'm amazed at how many guys fight and they have like cups.
They're a little loose in their jockstrap.
They have regular old cups.
Like you guys are out of your fucking shitty ones.
Pop right now.
Those diamond Emma made cups are so God damn good.
You'd have to be fucking crazy to wear anything else other than a tie cuff of
than a tie cup with the rope.
You just did it.
You'd have some crazy,
I never wore one and football.
It's
whatever,
man.
You let that fucking three piece set that baby bird just flop.
Good job
free
you.
I always wear one Eddie.
I never wear a cop.
No,
no,
there's a whole star.
Oh,
oh guys.
Sorry.
I would only wear one like a week or two weeks before a fight to get used to it
cause I was going to wear it at the fight,
but I would never,
never ever wear it training or anything.
I never wore a training once until I was rolling with Einstein.
He's trying to pass my guard and he shoved his knee right into my debt and I got
out of the class and I took my,
my jock strap off and it was filled with blood and the blood was coming out of
my Dick.
It was in the smashed by deck.
Yup.
I get smashed and I was trying to figure out if I should go to the hospital and
I figured,
well if it was my nose when I go to the hospital,
no.
So I said,
all right,
let me just go home and say it and that.
So I was feeling it didn't hurt.
So I said,
let me see if I could get it hard.
So I got hard and I jogged off.
I checked all good.
I jerked off and it came out like a,
like one of those chickens.
You ever get a chicken?
It's got an MRI on it.
That's all bloody and all.
You got any photos?
No.
So I pissed.
I pissed and came blood for three or four days,
but it never hurt.
I would have gone right to the doc to me to feel like under that scrutiny of,
hmm,
if it were my nose,
what my cock is so much more important than my nose.
I can say that it was good luck on your cock.
High grade missing.
No is going to suck your Dick
fucking skeletor do with his giant Dick.
Did He,
did he smash your balls or the trunk right into my Dick Hole.
Like it was like he was trying to happen,
you know,
it's that pass like when someone's trying to slice the knee through.
Yup.
And uh,
as you see,
he just made a mistake.
It's thanks.
I'm slammed in my day.
It was only one time.
It happened after.
Who knows how many years of training.
But that was it for me dog that got you weren't on Cialis if hard.
That's what I'm saying.
Well it probably would have absorbed it better or rip that all.
Like do you ever have a girl riding you and then slips out and then lands on it?
She's cause mine is too.
I know.
Got Us broken.
How about the homeboys?
Remember homeboy,
he got his Dick Broken.
I talked to him.
He was in a wheelchair.
I talked to that guy in a wheelchair after it happened and he told me exactly
what happened and how it broken half girl riding Romer.
Yeah.
Oh that's,
oh that's an a reckless girl.
He was in a wheelchair.
The real freaks out hold on earth a lot.
Everywhere I go,
two days broke.
The guy's an Emily fighter.
My,
I know a guy
kicked in the nuts from fighting and in his team he,
he's testosterone.
What got rid of though out later on in his life and the doctor said it's
probably because cause he had his one ball is bigger than the other because it
never swelled and everyone down doc said you injured your nuts fighting and
that's why,
that's probably why you're here.
There was one of the guys who was fighting the UFC was a training and he went to
spar with a buddy and he just didn't bother putting his cup on cause they were
just going to move around.
Light got kicked in the balls,
losses ball.
She said never.
Never.
Never seen him again.
No.
He went,
his ball exploded.
He got kicked in the ball and it's just the surgery.
Surgery.
You just leave it.
Are you going to do,
he started trying to read the door.
He used to do,
he'd take a cheese cloth,
your wrap it up,
tighten it down.
Now it's nothing.
It's like they removed it exploded.
I finally figured out,
you see those like spectacles where they have some guy gets kicked in the nuts
like really hard.
Like a Kung Fu guy would just stand that.
Well,
I figured out what he's doing because occasionally when I'm having sex,
like one ball of find a hiding place
go and then you just plop it out.
Yeah,
but they just must do that.
Go backstage and they just hide that fact.
Their ball flight science did a study on it and they said that actually fights
science,
not science.
What they do in movies.
A lot of times,
actually one at a time here.
What are their balls developed calcium deposits.
Brian,
their balls actually gets super hard from,
from trauma.
I feel like red bands,
not even here.
And I feel like,
oh Brian and I mean a little bit.
I'm telling you,
I realized real of the whole shot ski versus near.
They use our ski from a decade ago.
Look at this.
That,
I'll tell you what,
that Frank Mir,
Todd Duffy fight was
crazy.
How about big foot?
Couldn't take a punch at all then fight.
So a Aly and he's back can take a punch.
No problem.
I don't like that rematch with big foot Mark Hunt.
That's a legendary fight and now you've got to,
I don't like it man.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't take away from that fight.
I'm sorry.
But why thought Andre Arlovski was fighting for the title?
Why no cane is,
I dunno.
I thought that was the rumor.
No cane.
I think,
you know,
it was,
it was going to either be dos Joe's or uh,
uh,
Dosantos for other,
I don't know whether they'll do Dosantos ovary over him is begging for it.
Yeah,
they are doing that.
That's the fight.
But our Laskey cut.
Damn.
Look at this.
When he stopped Travis Browne.
God Damn,
he's back.
He's vicious.
Fucking striker.
You know the guy had some confidence problems and got killed a bunch of times,
but the end of the day,
that guy,
he's a vicious fucking Stryker.
How about for him?
Sticking through it?
What do you get knocked out four in a row many times.
Get them now.
Well,
watch his fight with carrots off in Strikeforce.
A tough fight to watch,
man.
You Watch that fight?
These fights over.
This is over.
Oh,
Todd Duffy.
God Damn Son.
Those are both similar fights.
Mere Duffy and very similar Travis Browne.
Yeah,
and a lot of ways,
right?
Just wild.
Except the end.
The 10 years was so definitive.
I mean mirrors.
There was no back from that.
I mean he could,
they could account it to a hundred up mayor too.
Man.
Here's another guy just stuck with it,
man.
Look at him.
Yeah.
He's just got to think about just a few years ago,
he was like,
what?
What does he want it out of his last six?
How about when Josh Barnett crushed him?
Just like two years ago?
Josh Barnett crushed him two years ago.
Now he's on the verge of a title shot.
Chad la priests,
Cisco Train Aldo Turn Aldo fought one 85 at ultimate fighter in Brazil and now
he's won 55
crazy
dude.
Chad,
the priests coming out with a cross on the,
the ivy thing doesn't start talk Tober correct.
Exactly.
That's why this December five with all those going to be real problematic for Mr
Mcgregor.
Cause Mr McGregor cuts a fuck load of weight.
So it does all of the Yup.
Both guys do.
They both look like they just got to start cutting early.
So does Weichman though.
Why did cuts a shitload?
Oh well you know this is the conversation that I had with um,
if it scales like they have to add weight classes.
They have to but the UFC doesn't want to add weight classes cause they think it
waters down the sport.
Yeah.
I don't have too much.
She had a fan of that.
I think there's enough weight classes leave it the way they are,
does not deal with it.
But there's not this giant jumps.
There's a 20 pound champ.
It does matter.
One 85 to two oh five is a huge jump.
That's fine guys.
Mason items anyway though.
They're still doing,
but it's,
you're not transcend three way.
You're not fighting.
If you were fighting,
you wouldn't be fine with know.
I know,
maybe for the fighters it could be better,
but for the sport we have enough weight.
I'm with Joe Man,
because a lot of these guys,
look,
we get heavyweight two oh six or two 65.
It's fucking insane.
It's a nice problem.
I like it.
No it's not.
It's interesting as a fighter,
it's not cool man.
As a fighter.
No audience member.
I'm going to him about the fighters I'm talking about.
You mean there's no fast track of his life that it is too much already.
We don't need more.
You do though.
Cause cause what about,
what about guy like Chris Weidman,
he's a bad motherfucker.
Like the champion right now.
He's doing 10 to 20 to 15 not big boy.
He's doing for himself.
He's 85.
He needs to uh,
in between the camps.
Maybe not blow up as much.
Not and you don't understand.
He's not blowing up.
He's dehydrated.
He's going to be five [inaudible] two or five [inaudible] at 200
200 huh?
What if his optimal weight to perform that 200 I liked the way classes the way
they are.
I don't want it anymore.
You don't find a problem.
Only you're going to saint,
you're not using any logic.
You just saying you like,
hey the heavyweight class that,
that argument,
that is ridiculous.
Especially when you like the heavyweights are so poor.
They're six really great heavyweights.
And then the rest is just hard to got guys that are that big that are really
moving the envelope like that.
And,
and a lot of those guys are tool fibers.
Easy,
easy to fibers.
And so if you had a weight class that started at two 30 that was reasonable to
have a guy that's like a Frank Mir Santa Cruz for huge and have a guy fight at a
300 pound man on the day low.
Yeah.
It's up to Joe's point.
Do you care if Conor McGregor and Aldo fought at one 51 60 to any of us give a
fucking hair?
No,
I don't care.
We want to see the best we want.
I want to see the guys.
I want to see the best fighter at the best way.
Then you need more weight classes.
I mean like I'd rather see,
I ran see Aldo if all the fights better and faster and longer and with more
intensity at one 55 around see that classes.
I think the way classes,
the way they are forced up fights more instead of going,
well,
I'm in this weight class and I'm in this one.
I disagree.
You can see more super fights where people meet in the middle for a belt,
you know,
like it's what it should be.
This should be belts are bullshit.
That's it.
Who Cares?
What are the best fighters of the best fighters?
We all know who the best fighters are,
right?
Have the best fighters fight the best guys.
When you beat the best guys,
you're the best fighter.
This idea that champion and I,
I just think at a certain point in time,
who cares when,
if all has the belt look,
Mcgregor has,
let's be honest,
McGregor has an illegitimate belt.
Sure.
Okay made up.
It's a made up belt.
I mean we call it the interim belt,
but Aldo defended his title a year ago.
Stripping a guy because he doesn't,
because he can't get through a camp without getting injured is a part of MMA.
It's always been a part of them and bay.
But because of the marketing,
because the hype behind it,
because of the huge event,
the enormity,
the,
the economics of the event,
they decided to make it an interim fight.
So he's got a title.
All those got a title.
They both have titles.
So they're fighting for the undisputed title.
So it becomes this big thing that they have to get on a scale and they have to
have a certain amount of mass in their body and then they rehydrate like crazy
and do their best to get back up to whatever the fuck they really are.
Wouldn't it be better if they just fought?
I like big Conor is we know have big Aldo.
Is this go fight guys that make sense?
If you didn't have belts like that or do you have,
uh,
mitigated value to them?
You could have catch fight for everybody.
Yeah.
You could go,
okay judge Jones,
what do you want to fight Weidman at?
Or what do you like or whatever.
You could do any of that stuff with every single fight and then it would be real
matchups that was that he has off adds another dimension.
So fighting to the biggest thing is that it does become,
if you're sucking inordinate amounts of weight,
it kind of a part of being a champion then has to be how good is your nutrition
program,
how good is your weight loss program?
And that becomes a huge part of fighting when it probably shouldn't.
What about more brain trauma?
Correct.
Cause cause the other homeboy,
Jeff Novitsky was saying that it takes 72 hours to rehydrate your brain.
So even with Ivy,
no belt,
you guys are saying no belts,
just catch.
Wait no,
no,
I want belts but let's do more divisions.
So guys aren't killing themselves to make the best athlete in the UFC.
He's amazing and they're doing an amazing job and like Jay likes add this and
add that.
I don't even funny if you took your mask off and you weren't Eddie and you were
actually Dana [inaudible] does.
There's so much good shit happening in the UFC too much that you can't even keep
trying not to add more weight to.
Doesn't matter.
They take away the belts.
This is the logical discussion because not that they're not doing all these
reasons why more weight classes would be beneficial and not cutting weight will
be beneficial and you're like,
everything's great.
It's a crazy way it looked was maybe he's super
positive.
He might be super positive me one of those beers.
Right.
Good beer by the way,
take,
you know what?
I appreciate you.
Yeah,
it would be safer and it'd be easier.
It'd be better for the fight.
We get better performances if they weren't killing themselves.
That's the name of the company and trying to get me in trouble.
Okay,
what are we going to look?
What's going on open about Chad lips,
perfect screw yas fucked up judges and all that shit.
You never know who's gonna win.
Fuck yeah.
That's adds to the excitement.
I love that.
Please.
And what he has.
Okay,
guys,
back off.
I'm appreciative.
I love the belts and all that shit.
I love the fact that if you're a champion and,
and uh,
uh,
knowing that if you,
if you don't take this fight,
if you try to back off for whatever reason,
maybe maybe you fake an injury,
maybe you don't,
they can injury.
Maybe you don't want to get busted with steroids and there,
whatever it is.
I think it's good for them to know that if you fuck around,
we're going to strip that fucking belt.
I like that.
Oh,
I'm not gonna fight.
I hurt my ankle.
Oh,
I hurt my shoulder.
You know what I mean?
You never know.
It's nice to know that you can't do that shit anytime you want.
When take your fucking belt and we're going to make you guys fight.
That's ridiculous.
But the change champion,
a champion gets hurt and training.
If they are clean and they actually do get hurt and they can't fight,
you're just going to take their belts.
ADDS excitement.
No,
you're talking crazy.
Oh,
come on.
You guys start a fighters' union
trouble.
He listen.
I love what's going on.
I love this shit.
And you love it too.
I haven't fucking podcast because he'd been watching the fights.
Who's the woman who's fighting is a better question for you.
Is that,
is that an American black guy or is that a person that black guy firsthand?
It's hard to tell.
Oh,
he's a nice right hand.
your shit rowing.
He's no joke.
It would be,
it's good to be a handful and the right.
You know what I mean?
Guys that got the Jersey is color coded by the way.
Eddie said it give you a little heads up.
Green on the shorts.
One guy where it was like a green out in the stores to make them all with the
Santa Ana.
Ooh.
By the way,
has anybody worn,
like,
have you ever seen someone wearing like those Reebok fighter kits?
Have you ever run into anybody in the street?
Haven't seen one.
I got the pants when I was doing an Andrew Craig.
Come on Emily.
Oh yeah.
They had them all laid out in a locker and wow.
They make you a snake.
Oh Damn.
I missed it.
Dad,
did they make you wear sneakers?
10% socks too.
Everything.
Only my underwear.
Socks.
Wow.
Oh,
he pulled guard.
The only kid I've ever seen was that Aubrey Marcus's house.
It was hanging in your closet and I was like,
oh cool.
I saved my shit from the Ben Saunders fight.
It's all bloody.
I saved that shit.
That'd be brutal if they made you give it up and then they sold it.
Sign it.
They sell it at Ebay.
Warren kits.
Oh Hey.
That's your heart.
It's going to ruin it.
Yes.
Once over,
and this is definitely going to ruin his brain.
All these count,
all these counts,
but the downward elbow right down that for non trend now though is a bad
motherfucker.
Those aren't that hard.
They'll stop it though.
Shit Bitch.
Damn.
Wow.
Nice.
Holy Shit.
Francisco tree.
Now Aldo,
where is a Saskatoon by the way?
Ask a ton on the map,
isn't it?
He gets the capitalist this catch.
Was that what it is?
Is that Hey Chris?
Beall already flat.
Right.
Sounds good.
What happened Chris?
Beall fun.
Is that what you said?
I'll find that a black guy,
right?
Yes,
man.
I was watching Gracie worlds with Tate met at loss.
I didn't keep track of the prelims,
ma'am.
Sad that Sam stock.
I came to first around what happened to Chris Beall.
I'm trying to find out right now.
Prelim results.
Fuck man.
Super Bummer for Sam.
Sam retired.
He retired in the octagon after the fight.
Um,
man,
uh,
do do,
do,
do to Arantes beat Joe boy tapped them out.
Wait.
Crispier lost.
Uh,
no.
Jewel boy is not Chris Beall said your boy.
Hold on.
He said he beat her boy.
He's watching her spiel.
I think you wanted decision.
I think I'll tell you right now.
Um,
no.
Be a lost decision,
Joe.
Yeah,
I wasn't watching Khloe.
20th.
We'll just split decision.
It was close by.
Yeah.
Oh No,
no,
it wasn't split decision.
29,
28,
27 30 for the Greek gentlemen.
See you trained with him and he's been coming.
Okay.
Bad motherfucker.
Crispier hell yeah,
he is,
dude.
It's heartbreaking,
man.
You guys know him.
He's such a good dude and he just can't take a shot anymore.
And he's a good dude.
He,
but whenever we've seen it so many times,
guys that had of an iron chin and then all of a sudden they reach a certain
point,
they can't take it anymore.
And the guy that's always cut a lot of weight,
you know,
like a real legend,
but always,
always cut a lot of weight and like,
yeah.
And then that,
that stuff's real.
It stays with you.
And then the training,
you know,
like you always train,
always being hit.
There's never a rest.
Yeah.
It was interesting.
You guys watch the ultimate insider,
Jon Anik shell good show.
And they had,
I were shot on,
Rashad was talking about how he used to train now he trains now and they used to
think that you had to beat yourself up so that you know you could be able to
fight.
And he's like,
no,
that doesn't really work.
He's like,
it's a good theory.
Yeah,
it's good in theory,
but in actual practice you just can't do that.
I think the thing is,
I mean the smart way,
I think that there's only a few guys that are doing it,
but the,
and I think Rhonda probably does it,
but,
um,
the only good thing about sparring a lot is that you,
it's not like you're staying sharp.
I think you're just learning.
You're tough and you learn,
you can withstand stuff.
You're not getting better.
But to hit mits,
to work on timing,
all that stuff.
Like I think after the first couple,
three years of your fight,
you don't need to spar ever.
What was Kennedy Down?
You just don't,
yeah.
Tim Kennedy we're talking about and he goes on.
I don't spire it all.
Yeah,
he was what I wanted and needed.
I can take a shot because I've been fighting for how long he's,
I'm gonna I don't spar at all.
I just feel he's,
the only time we go live is when I'm inside the octagon.
And I've heard this from a number of fighters and there's a trend in NFL too,
in college.
There's a lot of college teams.
They do not hit any more.
There's no more life practice.
These are top,
top teams.
Don't you pay a price though when,
when you're going full and distance and like,
I dunno.
Well,
when he doesn't make a difference in speed,
distance and deform,
you've been doing it for that long.
Do you really?
You know what I'm saying?
And you're hitting targets.
You're you,
you've got a guy hit and miss.
It's just like hitting somebody in the face,
right.
You know your footwork is the same.
You know the guys that are holding mitts for these guys on the top or the
fucking finest fighters in the world that are now holding Mintzberg simulated
and get like a,
a Bang Ludwig or a Mike Winkeljohn,
Brandon Gibson.
It's like those guys are fucking killers.
Don't get it.
It has some serious power.
He is so frightening.
I'd go into the gym and he'd been in the early in the morning and holding it and
like,
and I'd hear what,
what,
what?
Like just somebody beating the fuck out of a bag and it's just him back there.
It's dark.
It's so fucking eerie.
And there's a bag taking a beating.
He was a world champ,
right?
We're multiple times kicked by.
Bad,
bad.
Let's compare them.
Compare them to so many power wise,
like a Melvin,
Melvin Manhoef kind of,
I don't know.
What I heard is ridiculous kicks.
Daniel,
you're looking at him going,
I go,
what's your workout?
What are you doing on the bag?
He goes,
I'm doing nine minute rounds and,
and it's just nonstop.
You don't,
you don't.
It's like,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
It's like the cadences fucking crazy.
How big is he big guy?
Was he a heavyweight or one 85 one 98 he's probably not even that big,
but I just keep hearing from people that go,
dude,
you,
you need to see that guy kicked the bag.
I say,
they say it's ridiculous power.
Such a good dude.
The work ethic is,
I mean it's amazing that he's a,
he's one of the toughest,
kindest,
most gracious dudes ever helps everybody.
Well,
he,
he's the one training Holly Holmes,
right?
Yeah.
He's Holly Holmes.
Been Holly.
I mean he's been Holly's coach for four for a [inaudible] Jamie.
She was a boxer for try not to talk over each other though because we've got a
lot of mikes going on.
We got five,
seven legs.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know man.
Um,
the Holly Holm fight is not,
the,
is intriguing to me as a Amanda Nunez would be.
I would just like to see Holly get maybe another one or two warmups because
we've seen her in the octagon and she's just not putting it together yet to get
to that level of Rhonda and our big issue is the grappling,
you know,
that's a huge issue for the Rondo.
Yes.
She's very patient too.
That's,
that's not really gonna work against Ronda.
She's going to run,
is going to come right after.
Well that she won't have time to be patient.
It's another thing,
another drawback,
I think being such a fine boxer in that arena,
you can be patient.
You can't eat it.
It's a,
it's a long drawn out battle.
Rhonda doesn't fight that way.
Who knows though?
Man,
you never know.
I mean maybe Holly,
because her standup is so much more refined.
She's been doing it for so much longer.
Maybe she can keep Rhonda away from her.
Let's fuck knows I'm serious.
I just think,
I just think honestly,
the real problem is,
is there's a lack of talent.
Do I?
Like I said,
I'm not mad at the UFC.
I get it,
man.
Let's,
let's at least let the world know who Holly is.
She didn't get all this marketing.
Ron is only a fight for so long.
Holly is a bad ass.
Whoever's managing Cyborg.
I think there's plenty of criminal.
Rhonda is way better.
He's made.
That's what I know.
He fired.
She fired him.
Yes.
They still train together though.
She needs to get with Mc Hammer.
Go ahead and go.
That was,
he was doing that for a while,
right?
My manager's son.
How's an MC Hammer?
I was an MC hammer,
right
in a rap video,
but I wasn't dancing.
What did you do in this room?
He's not in a,
in MMA no more.
What happened?
Uh,
you can't test this.
Du,
Du du Du.
Seriously though.
I wondered what happened to Mc Hammer's he's still,
uh,
he's not involved in killing the gay man.
He's an investor in Facebook,
sales force,
gold money for gold or whatever it goes for goals.
Oh,
so he's blown up,
dude.
No more MMA as a businessman.
So I think it really perform anymore.
He does.
He does,
man.
I just saw him a digital to Vegas for the next 20 years.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
He went,
you went to see him.
You know he came here and you left the house.
I worked with a man to go see.
No,
he,
he's got all those big sponsors that everyone was giving me shit for.
All of those came from Mc Hammer,
salesforce,
all that momentum and had the pants.
AIRBNB.
No,
I wish he sells out.
He sells out in like Africa and shit.
You know,
like he was like,
that was the funniest thing.
[inaudible]
and shit.
Well like in China,
expendable 17 huge.
But here we're like,
what?
This is a good fight.
Coattail and Berkman.
It's a throwback to 2006
the numbers he does in the Congo,
I'm serious.
This holy Shit.
Open air jungles,
Jujitsu with the GE.
Every day I improved with the g notice I'm doing things and no one can do in the
fight because they don't have the grip.
No,
he did not say that.
This is three years since became a black belt.
Today is going to give him the first black stripe Charles on the van.
He had that piece of tape and his fucking color.
That was awesome.
I'll get us learned to Technia to you go.
Oh my friend,
my friend.
I think the girls in the game too right now,
they got to realize they got way more power than they think because there is
such a small amount of them that are,
I mean how you both fighters.
Yeah,
man.
Right.
I don't.
Who else are you going to get when you're looking at at women to fight Rhonda.
Holly Holmes is the baddest woman walk in.
I think she's bad ass.
I think it's early for whatever,
whatever,
however it take.
How many more out there?
Five tape my eggs like that.
You have seen the tough show,
so Rhonda could,
my mom could fight Rhonda at UFC when Itunes,
they'd still sell it.
Sell as many papers.
It does not.
He fights.
That's true.
It does not matter.
Best Coin.
We don't,
America didn't know the fuck she is.
Holly Holmes Eda.
We know she is [inaudible] still going to sell this bitch out Jones when he was
in his prime and he's just starting their matter yet does not.
Roy Jones world tour.
You know we're,
we're paying to see Ronda beat up.
Whoever.
Ron is going to have to do things now she's going to have to do like a judo
master in the day and then have like
basketball.
That's right.
He played basketball the day of a world title defense the day of,
not the day before day of played basketball and then went out.
Whoops.
In acid at night.
One of my favorite stories about that is like a,
is John Jones chasing a guy down a robber,
a purse.
Snatcher in New York City.
Fucking rubs him down and tackles him,
retrieves the person.
Lady holds the guy for the cops and then goes,
who's he knock out Shogun,
right for the title.
Oh,
the youngest ever champion.
That's like a made up story that John Jones,
someone's making that Jon Jones movie writer.
He's back training by the way is there's footage of him train at Jackson's went
right away.
Right after he got in that trouble.
Mr Winklejohn was like,
you're,
you're back in help all the rest of the guys,
whatever you're doing,
you're doing,
but help these guys.
And he was in right.
He's a good,
he's a stand up dude man.
The whole division is like ye he's training again.
I saw him doing crunches.
Well here's the problem.
Like what's going to happen with him criminally?
You know,
it's a legit running away from,
it's a big fucking deal running away from a tonality,
right Joey?
Cause she got,
she got bones broken.
She's a serious injury.
If there's factory he didn't and not only that,
he was of mine to come back and get whatever he needed from his car and then
leave again.
The problem with that is there go,
I mean,
I'm not saying he should lie,
but there's a defense that you could always use in a car accident that you got
hit so hard in the head.
You didn't know what the fuck you're doing and then you left.
You know when no one could use that argument better than a guy like Jon Jones.
Why is it taking so long?
I don't know how long it to figure this out.
I hate to say this.
That's why they always say,
if you are in a situation and you're drunk,
people in the know will run away from the scene.
Sure.
As you can say,
I hit my head and I was disoriented.
There's no way to prove that you weren't exactly.
Scene is not.
You can fit the defense and it,
Ryan's is,
I didn't know where I was.
I know he came back.
He got cash.
The numbers,
the difference with this is that somebody was hurt.
Makes it felonious.
If you're just leaving the scene,
not as bad a deal as a drunk driving,
hurting somebody leaving the scene.
Dude,
way worse.
I love the fact you used the word felonious.
Munk come with it.
That should be a rapper.
Felonious monk.
You know I set up felonious monk probably is a rat.
I bet.
I bet you're right.
Let's look it up right now.
I bet you're totally right.
Joan's bet you're wrong.
I bet that's the easy Eddie.
That's your shit.
Joe Shapiro.
Come back.
Take for dooms bell and take fucking,
that's exactly what's gonna happen.
He's gonna come for lunch.
Yeah,
there's the guy,
his name's felonious monk.
Monk was it.
It was a great pianist and he went crazy.
The loneliness,
just my crazy great jazz piano actually might try the best jazz pianist.
You can keep them.
How about that?
Genius.
You've got the nicest I've ever seen.
I went to the Le La County Museum of art the other day.
Save Your fucking brain cells.
Save your time.
I want to show you some pictures.
There was a,
I'm not bullshitting.
There's a plexiglass box on the ground.
It was roped off I go.
Is that the art?
That's the art.
It is a plexi glass box and there's some bullshit written on the wall.
What this box is supposed to represent,
it's a fucking box.
I paid money to see a box.
It's a box where your kids born out of their mind.
They were ready to run through walls.
There's a critic who said the reason that those kinds of things sold for
millions of dollars because a small group of people who are modern art
aficionados wanted to be and feel really exclusive.
It was this Angela hauls ass holes.
We go back.
The art there is so bad.
There's one,
one piece of art.
There's a screen that has 18 different separate videos playing at the same time.
It's just people like throwing a ball to each other.
One guys juggling one guy smoking a cigarette is so fucking dumb.
It's so dumb.
It made me angry.
I was like,
I can't show you.
Fucks made me look at this.
One of them was supposed to represent tar and feathering,
so it was like a black background with some feathers on it.
Like,
I'll fucking kill you a fucking kill you if you put this in a museum,
paid to get in there and day.
I didn't have to pay either because I'm a fucking resident of La County.
I could've got in for free.
I got to be a celebrity.
I'm like,
what's contribute?
Let's contribute.
So we paid to get in and there's nothing more maddening than it modern art
exhibit,
especially the art that came out of the 60s and Seventies Rauschenberg and those
guys.
And not only that man fuck people that were so fucking pretentious.
There's one of them is junk.
They have an art exhibit just they called junk and you'd go there and it's just
a garbage they've glued in frames.
It's so fucking stupid.
There's someplace that they just opened where they opened it to a lot of street
artists and they just had blank walls in there and then they let that go,
which I think has huge potential to be bad ass.
Well,
some street artists are fucking super town.
You know,
Justin Blue Blues.
He did a place by clutch,
um,
that these,
he is wicked red bands,
like red bands.
The one who really term,
like he texts me,
he goes,
hey dude,
because Justin LewisLewis' daughter trains at my school and I don't know any
artists.
I know Todd white.
That's it.
And uh,
I didn't know who Justin boots.
I'm not,
I'm not big in the art world.
I don't know.
He,
he uh,
he's in,
uh,
he's in a painter of lots of shit,
but he's known for painting hip hop artists and doing a weird looking like
paintings of them that are insane.
He's got books and you know,
anyways,
um,
what the band wanted me to,
uh,
well that's what you're about to do.
His own podcast.
I've been telling them forever.
Do you have all these interests that I don't have in there?
Like you should do your own podcasts.
You'd be good at a podcast.
Just start yelling thing.
He doesn't do his own,
doesn't have six Terry,
here's this thing called dysentery,
but it's just gets girls on and gets drunk.
And harasses him what it's called,
the sexual harassment of Brian Red Bat.
That's the name of the podcast.
What I'm saying is you should do like a show where he has guests on call with
the red band show that no he doesn't.
No,
he doesn't have any single podcasts.
That's like the red band show.
He does kill Tony.
He does all of them with other people,
but he would be good one on one.
He'll,
he knows what he knows that he's,
that he's like the engineer guys like the doctor Dre of podcast.
Well,
he doesn't even act as an engineer on my show anymore.
He'd sit says,
oh,
like a cohost.
You know,
I think he's better off when he's not distracted by computers in front of them
and all this stuff.
First of all,
he's so add,
he'll just start googling things.
I'll catch him going on his Facebook and like we're doing a show,
like put your phone down just for a show.
But that's how his mind is.
Like if you go to dinner with him,
he's like that.
If he's like,
but that's also why he's got so much information on stuff that's going on in the
Internet and you know,
I mean he'll tell you,
look,
I'm looking for things to talk about like yeah,
but you got to kind of like talk in an actual conversation.
It's not as fun.
But what I'm saying is he would probably recognize that more if he was doing his
own show.
Like if you did like the red band show and it's like it's not,
you don't have time for it.
You only do my show like once or twice at the most a week and you have all
these,
other days you don't have another job like you should do.
It's like you could be really good at it.
I think he would really have a huge market because I think he's a weird guy.
He's funny.
He says a lot of crazy silly shit.
He's got a lot of varied,
bizarre interests.
I think it would help him like it would help him like so people could see like
what he's really all about,
what people like about them.
It'd be better for him.
It helped his comedy for sure.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
And then like a guy like this guy,
like this artist or you know,
it would expose people to things that he's into cars.
He's into a lot of,
uh,
I mean I find out about a lot of stuff from them.
Yeah.
All of that is another thing to stop doing that.
And he had a regular time and he had to be true to somebody else.
He invited a guest,
it would hone it.
Oh No,
did we just lose direct TV?
Oh Wow.
DIRECTV almost shit.
Couple 35 year olds going at it.
He lost.
He had to suck a lot of ways.
I think that for almost everybody that is involved in standup comedy,
doing your own podcast is a great idea.
Unless you don't need a,
you're a Russell Peters or Louis C K why bother?
You know?
But for anybody else,
look at guy like me or for Bill Burr,
I'm sure it's been gigantic for his career.
For a Joey Diaz has been gigantic,
has been Diana.
For you,
it's been doing it for you.
For me,
it's been fucking amazing.
Been a lifesaver for me,
man.
For me too.
I think it's a,
it's the best form of communication.
I just think more people should define what's true to them.
And there's like some people that are were I've seen like I know podcasts where
guys,
they work with other guys and they fucking wind up hating each other.
Like Eddie if tad that with Jim Jefferies,
they had this great podcast together but they couldn't keep it together together
now.
And he's got his own things talking the shit.
He's had three different ones like that Eddie's gone through.
Yeah.
What was that about?
They just didn't get along.
It's hard man.
Sometimes you want to talk and they're talking and sometimes you disagree and
you don't want to discuss certain things or the things that you think are
interesting they think or dom and never had you get mad.
Never had that with my boy over here.
Well that's one of the reasons why you guys work so well together.
You guys have an interesting dynamics and you know when you say ridiculous shit
that it's ridiculous and so you play along with it when everybody shits on you
cause you're kind of semi-serious when you first bring things up and then you're
not married to it.
You realize along the way when you've said why is it just hit him with a right
hand here for sure Brian,
he would think and then it becomes,
you kind of go with it.
No guys,
guys,
I box.
That's technically I was reading a study and it's a fact actually that's like,
why don't you Shaun Gladwell's the box?
And I was like,
it looked like,
I feel like I could navigate that kind of like that movement.
I wouldn't get lit up sometimes because I'm watching it and I'm like,
Oh God,
comedy Berkman is so relaxing.
Like that same personality he was talking about you like you go out and you say,
fuck,
I wish I was a big,
I wish throwing thing.
Meanwhile we're missing a good fight.
So really good fight.
Bergman's lighten them out.
He saw a lot of these guys,
man,
these guys know what is up.
I think I got coattail winning via Tko.
Well,
I
taste chunk Jitsu has really improved,
really improved.
I was really impressed with his takedowns and his Jujitsu in his last fight.
He was the longest was with Anderson with Anderson.
Well before that Louis,
well,
you exposed a fundamental flaw in Anderson's game to this.
If you don't lead,
he doesn't either.
True.
Oh,
no joke man.
He stood in Lombard's face,
man.
This guy choked.
I choked out.
John Fitch and one round put him to sleep.
That's right.
I forgot to call them in that guillotine.
Put him to sleep.
He's a fucking veteran.
He's been very good.
It was very good and world series of fighting and then he doesn't swear to
coming back.
He doesn't want to fight in the UFC.
Fought Lombard came in short notice and wasn't,
wasn't feeling well for that fight.
They fought stun gun and got to get choked.
Is that we lost by a burden as much.
Which kind of truck because he's lost four in a row.
I think it's how you what man.
I will always keep a guy like Berkman around.
He makes shit interesting.
Yup.
Swings to the fences.
He's very smart.
He's a good dude.
Oh Dude.
Fucking hurt
man.
I lost you lost the leftover from that left hand.
He tagged him with when he was,
oh dude.
He hits hard and you know what else about Bergman?
He's real calm in there.
Very.
He gets,
he gets real relaxed.
He doesn't spend his energy.
He also went through like some significant injuries with his back where he
healed it up in some weird way.
He was talking to me about it and I really didn't understand it and I wanted to
go more in depth to them but he said he did like balance work and like,
um,
it was like positive thinking.
What kind of injury are we talking about?
Barbell of bulging bulging from west side barbell.
He broke his back like five,
five different ways.
Louie Simmons and Shane Sweat.
He's one of his main instructors is saying that.
That's why he developed the reverse hyper machine specifically to heal his back
and he healed his back by himself.
Five breaks in his fucking spine.
They all wanted to cut them open.
They all want to fuse his discs.
That's a bad dude,
man.
He's a bad motherfucker.
You guys talk about transfer of power man in a huge way where it's like when you
see tip tap boxing and all that stuff and what is making guys turn it over?
Like that stuff is trained.
Like you can change.
Like everybody's like,
oh,
he's got knockout power.
He does it.
It's like you can give that to somebody.
You can train yourself into that.
I've never seen anybody that has a pitty Pat Punch.
You become a bomber.
True the fence.
Look at Berkman or either you,
nobody trains it either,
but you like a George Foreman guy.
You don't have to train that shit [inaudible] with these guys,
Eugene Jackson,
but it doesn't mean that it's outside of the realm of others possibility.
If that is true.
I mean,
I think it has to do with your ability to cover distance in a very quick amount
of time,
but it also has to do with bone mass.
Bone mass is undeniable when it comes to punching.
It's not us.
It's not a weird secret that people with giant hands hit way fucking harder.
It just,
it just,
they just did little Datsun.
He's not a huge guy by any means.
Explosive and he puts guy's down.
He's so,
he's so fast.
Explosive.
When he turned he was born,
he turns his head.
No,
no,
no.
He's,
he's got some speed.
Like every movement that he makes is 100% this is a good fucking fine.
I short elbows,
slept on Berkman.
I thought he was gonna get starched by Hector Lombard,
a juiced up.
Hector Lombard.
He freaking out,
man.
Yeah,
he's tough as fucking pop for juice.
Oh Jesus.
These guys going off and [inaudible] is fucking top God.
He's tough man.
He's one of the toughest guys as far as like his ability to take a shot and keep
his confidence.
He looks like he's in a different weight class.
10 Bergman.
Well he has,
he's a fight for the title and he was a tool five or to Tito.
Tito down.
Surprised him all the bad mother fucker.
Look at him.
He's got a lot better with his grappling.
His grappling has really improved in a big way.
Athlete.
Hello?
It's fucking hurt.
Why?
They ain't say that's pretty good.
I love Bergman.
He's still hurt,
man.
He's still hurt.
He doesn't have,
he doesn't know where he was when he threw that idea.
Wow Man.
Wow.
I'm over here trying to pretend I'm unphased by that.
I'm just going to walk in the right direction.
My coaches,
Jesus Christ,
that when he caught,
when he caught Patrick with that shot and you know guys hit pretty well when
he's like,
I'm going to just change direction and go right for a double leg right now.
Not even think about it like
that single leg is not finished all that often,
but someone who does it really well.
I think it's Shogun.
Like I see him finish that single leg a lot.
The best is DC.
If he gets a hold on.
Listen,
you're like,
you're going for a ride.
I don't,
I'm not a rest so I don't really know.
But he seems to do it.
Do it.
And you can ask snap,
straighten your leg out and snap you down.
But in my opinion,
the scariest is normal.
Go Madoff,
Nema.
Go read off that mother fucker out grapples.
Everybody true.
Like you seem him get a hold of people.
He just rag dolls everybody.
So way he's doing it.
That's so confusing.
Like dos Anjos is strong as fuck and he's a really good grab bar and when you
see him fight Namaka man off number got mad.
I was like,
Eh,
not today.
I think you'll be on bottom for a while.
Eat and elbow sandwiches.
He beat those Angeles Buddy.
He beat everybody that combat sock.
Oh right hand combat sambo world champions.
Nampa Boise also high level wrestler.
Oh,
he can wrestle for sure.
Background is primarily soundbite.
I don't know if he has experience as well.
A lot of Greco in that shit.
Is Greco.
Tony got a little better wrestling then.
Uh,
no.
Rafael dos Anjos.
Tony Ferguson.
Oh,
you're saying better wrestling then dos Anjos.
Yes.
Ooh,
that's tough.
Come on man.
Tony.
Tony has a real wrestler.
I agree.
Don't say Angeles is a world champion.
Grab Honi wrestled in high school and college and that American.
He's a jet.
Freestyle and mark.
Trust me,
he's,
I'm talking about UFC grappling,
wrestling,
Jiu Jitsu guy.
He's from Brazil.
There's three wrestlers in Brazil.
I know
they have a team.
Try Out.
How weird was it that hit not the bubble.
Lou was that MMA Brazilian MMA fighter.
That was a wrestling Daryl goal.
Gold was the only Brazilian.
He does have a lot of big races come out of Brazil.
Lou was a restaurant,
you know,
it does an amazing job with a single leg is a,
is a clever to Sherif the way he runs a pipe.
That's a great restaurant.
Another Brazilian basic pike run.
A lot of Brazil is getting arrested now,
don't get me wrong.
Can do couple of of capital when you're raised
that way.
When you go into junior high school and you're wrestling and then you're going
to high school.
He told me you're going to call it.
I mean those Brazilian guys,
I can't talk over each other.
I'm going to explode if it fell over.
Grabs your leg.
If you're single,
like he's the one guy that you're,
you're take down the fence.
It probably is going to work too.
Well,
you know it's,
you're doing basic stuff too.
It was really impressive.
There's a video of your boy Cyborg,
the other Cyborg.
Roberto Bruno Cyborg.
Go brew.
Yeah.
He's doing these drills.
God damnit.
Chi Moves.
Good Tornado.
He's doing drills like guard pastorals.
Jamie,
go to look at Cyborg Bjj on,
on Instagram and pull up the video swatch.
How he moves for 235 pound guy.
You're kind of out.
He gets,
he passes me on the belly and then he guy rolls into him and then he jumps to
the back.
Dude,
he,
you saw the video today with it today and I'm talking about a video from like a
week ago.
Oh,
well I'm sure he's got a bunch.
Did you post it Joe?
No,
he posted it.
We'll get this watch at jetty.
Eddie jetty.
I'm sorry.
Eddie.
Watch this.
No,
no.
This is a different one,
Jamie.
This is him.
That's him.
That's just a escape that he does.
That one.
That one right hand corner.
This is wash the shit.
Watch this past.
Look how fast this motherfucker,
he's a big guy,
man.
Look at this for a guy this big to move that.
Well.
I mean fuck freak.
What's its ear guards brother?
How dare you?
How dare beautiful.
I mean,
I'm so impressed with that.
I,
I mean,
I can't imagine that's a 240 pound man that can move like that.
That's fucking crazy.
That's how big he is,
right?
He's about two 42 40 man memoirs.
Think it was two 30.
He's a fucking panther.
I mean he really is a panther that is freakish.
He beat Boucher at uh,
the left freak man.
He is as good as it gets when it comes to Brazilian Jujitsu fight.
Look at this man guys.
As good as it gets.
Yes.
It's a monster.
So strong.
He's different from a lot of those guys in like his physical preparation too.
He puts all these videos up of the strength and conditioning shit that he does
like NFL combine shit.
Mother fucker was a run in with rubber bands pulling them and shit.
It's a true pro.
He's a true bro.
He's like this real pro.
Yes.
His super rash.
Yeah.
Really Nice Guy.
Great Guy.
Real positive online.
Really like inspirational online.
I'm a huge fan of his I me too.
Cause you will you will you a bombed out that people were mad at you about that
metamorris bout oh you're talking about the shop shut down the shop shut down
for where Brendan Shop.
Just shut down all of his take downs and just made them,
you know,
made them kind of stand up there and realize if this fight,
if I don't want this fight to go to the ground,
you're not going to get me to the ground.
But then I went into his guard eight times.
Yeah he did after it was like,
you know what,
cool.
Check this out on your guide.
But the first thing you did,
and you did this within a couple of months of a UFC fight and everybody was mad
at you,
but I was like,
well listen,
you got to look at it this way.
The guy's a professional MMA fighter.
The the other guys fighting is known for Taryn needs to pieces like this is a re
all his Brockman will get that getting again,
it wasn't even that Joe,
it was more like,
uh,
well not even that loud when he signed up,
if it wasn't for that,
what the plan was to wear mouth.
I want to keep shooting,
keep shooting.
So I get a hold of his neck.
It's all my stuff is in transitions.
He knew this,
so he stopped shooting and then he just sat to is.
But I was like,
well we gotta get something going here.
So that's why I kept going to his guard.
No transition plan was to try to catch him as he was sharing.
Yes.
And then when he decides to it does bad,
I was like,
I didn't think of them like,
well fuck.
And then you get that kind of weird,
like she's not engaging.
I didn't,
you know,
even when you were actually grappling,
he never was able to put you in a weird position.
You should really do some out of Morris type shit,
dude,
I would love to,
man.
I don't know what Holocaust Bravo invitational.
Super fight in the heavyweight division.
Eddie,
who you got for him?
What's up Eddie in Austin,
Texas.
We might
want to do Cyborg.
I get someone else.
I want to see park to pass it.
I need somebody now that I know what she was trying to do to me is catch me when
you're not going to get for the turnover time.
Ebi overtime,
you ain't gonna be able to do that.
So I'm not worried about that because there's only one guy in the world who I do
that too.
And that Cyborg.
Hey,
you know what?
This is this.
When the rule set says that if there's no submission at the end of 15 minutes or
20 minutes,
it's a draw as an I would do the exact same thing if I'm going with the guy that
was fucking crazy dangerous.
I'd rather take the Goddamn draw then get choked out or,
or,
or I would do the same goddamn thing.
Well,
no,
that wasn't my plan at all.
Let's just go to a draw.
My,
my,
my plan was a choke his ass out in a dark store.
Get team.
That was the plan to get him shooting,
to open up and transition to the view submitted.
Signboard but that would be,
yeah,
I do.
That's why I signed up for it.
Holy Shit.
Like,
you know,
I would be super fucking cautious.
Cautious hundred percent.
I would be kind of this motherfucker.
This is a sidebar too.
God Damn bad motherfucker.
Oh look at this.
And he came out and hurting coattail Bergman.
Oh my God.
And he returns returns.
Wow.
We tagged him again.
He's wobbled.
Damn.
Berkman is so accurate.
Great fighter man.
He's so calm and the pocket.
It's the football super.
Yeah.
He doesn't get emotional.
It does.
He know he stays away calm.
Especially coming after him.
Oh,
he sees everything that way.
You know he's a,
he's a real veteran,
but soul's Code Tay man,
he really is Sicko.
Taize is commonly get under fire.
Go taste well,
the hardest hitters at 70 Jesus Christ is he though,
don't you think that like the cut down to one 70 has maybe diminished a bit of
that?
Cause it's hard.
He's not the same.
He's lost physical
side,
but he's still a big seven.
Yes.
He is big for sure,
but we haven't really been seen them knock guys out.
Did,
oh,
sorry.
I missed that last part.
What we say?
Oh my God.
How tough is Bergman?
How tough he is.
He's almost back.
Don't stop.
That.
Could that not have been,
that has never been a better timing ever.
You're like,
he's not really knocking guys out.
We're at one 70 they said to me,
Joe Rogan a Gary.
It's
great cut.
That's the third round.
And he's not tired at all.
That was fucking amazing.
I hope to fight.
What a fight.
And you gotta think how rocks he got early in that round?
Yes.
Well he was covering up and Berkman was going off on him.
That mother fucker is tough a shit.
Oof.
That was dope.
God Damn,
that right hand was picture perfect too.
It's a huge fight in front of all his fans to in Canada.
God Damn in a war.
That's like the sweetest victory because it's the one where you know,
you pull yourself out of the fire.
Fuck.
Like you see the benefits from your training.
You can't.
He was,
oh my goodness.
But that right hand was so beautiful.
Look,
I sets it up to faints with the jab first.
Hold Guy Josh Perkins.
Thomas.
Fuck.
Tough as fuck.
Berkman almost got up.
Yes.
You know what?
And I'll tell you what,
if they didn't stop the fight,
Berkman would have eventually gotten up.
Look,
watch what he does here.
He goes,
I don't want to come up.
I'm going to pull guard.
He rolls to his back here.
He's not like he's right there.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
They probably shouldn't have stopped it,
but either way.
Whatever that either though.
Powerful Patrick Otay.
Well he knows,
I mean he knows he got a bomb dropped on his chin.
I'm,
I'll tell you,
set it up to the pawing with the jab to get that distance then balloon fight of
the night so far.
Oh yeah.
I commentated a fight where the ref stopped it early and the guy was complaining
that he had stopped it early.
So the Rep said,
and this was all in the room,
said,
okay,
fight against the guy got knocked out again.
I don't want to throw the fire under the bus.
He's a really nice,
what organization?
King of kitsch too hot to handle.
And he was complaining,
why did you stop?
But I wasn't rock.
He goes,
you were out.
I wasn't rocking.
The Rep said,
all right,
let's go again.
And then he backed up in the corner and said,
you could see it in his eyes.
He's like,
fuck.
He never thought the ref would continue.
The fight isn't that happened in the EOC before where they're like,
no,
watch the replay.
You're unconscious.
Well,
not,
but the premier little Bustamonte had a tap.
Matt Lindland out twice.
Remember that?
Yeah.
Why?
What do you mean big?
John McCarthy fucked up Madelyn and he caught Matt Lindland Armbar Lindland
tapped and then he'd said he didn't tap.
So was just trying to change his position.
And so the main of fight again and then the next round Marillo I think caught
him in a guillotine.
Pretty sure he's gay teens,
but he had tapped them twice because a of uh,
you know,
it's an error by the rep,
Pedro.
I'm just trying to change the position.
Yeah.
Well I think,
I think John saw the arms fully straightened out.
Saw he's fighting.
Bustamante saw you didn't,
you didn't get no,
that's legit.
That's crossing Gracie's original squad of black belts.
Tall man to man is good.
And I'm Matt Lindland.
You know,
he's a fucking competitor.
You could say that about him.
He bit somebody while I was wrestling with him.
Yeah.
He was like,
uh,
one of his amateur wrestling matches.
He bits some dude who does call that tobacco in his like upper lip type tobacco
dude.
Straight Hillbilly Shit.
He was one of the toughest guys alive for a little while.
All that whole squad up there.
Yeah.
He was one of the toughest women,
85 pounders in the world.
Randy was up there like,
well,
that's when he fought David Tarell,
when David's role was a real threat dude,
he was knocked him out.
Dave trail was terrifying.
I remember him,
man.
Crap,
bleeding.
Grapplers quest.
He was,
uh,
he was just ripping heads off.
Yeah,
I heard it in the gym.
He's like the biggest freak.
He's a monster.
I heard.
He's an absolute nightmare to grapple with.
Well,
you should see him fucking new.
Go back and watch his early Abu Dhabi's to Dave Turo was a monster.
I'm familiar with him.
He's a super monster.
I'm a huge fan.
You know,
he had some see serious fucking infections in his ear from cauliflower where
they had to remove his ear.
They cut his ear off his head and had a scrape it out and there's all pos and
everything in there.
And they,
I think they had a windup cauterizing inside his ear.
He had some serious fucking ear problems.
No idea about that dude.
I'll cauliflower ear,
you know,
most of it he like look at Cortese right there.
Most of it is just cosmetic,
but there are times where you get ear problems where it goes deep inside the
year and you're in a big fucking terror.
We were seen as guys when they,
when like on the outside it's not a big deal,
but when that starts to close off and then they're,
they're hearing is mitigated.
Oh yeah.
And they get staff.
You get staff inside the rear too.
It's nothing that can happen.
Ah,
yeah.
It's fucking,
it's terrifying.
Oh my God.
What a perfect,
perfect timing.
Crazy that and put them out.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Right on the button co Tay [inaudible] still getting better.
It's amazing.
It's awesome to see him just,
he never loses his enthusiasm for the four.
It'd be cool veins as a button,
like a mute button where he gets say some shit that you wouldn't want to say on
air,
but he just want to tell everyone else.
Like what?
No,
I'm just saying something right now.
Right now with,
no,
no.
Like just throughout the,
throughout the general would be nice to have like a meal Voucher Code Tam.
Sure.
It's kind of sensitive.
It's thinking.
Maybe you're talking shit.
Hey,
I love Patrick Hotel.
Are you kidding Josh Burke men loved my daughter.
I'm just talking about general.
See that's a fight where I agree that you shouldn't almost shouldn't cut
Bergman,
so fucking the animal is an animal.
Why caught them is entertaining and by the way,
he beats a lot of guys in that division.
Tatagata guys give them the right match,
but there comes a point where you've beat so many good guys.
They're not going to give you those easy match ups.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you've beat,
you're such a veteran like this guy.
How about that match up?
Is there anybody more explosive than that guy?
Wasn't straight Outta Compton.
No,
I heard it was in it though.
Yeah.
Did you see him?
There's a video with him and this a bodybuilder guy and they're doing all these
bodybuilder exercises and say he might have the best body and they sent it to my
friend.
Who does he have the best body.
I sent it to my friends who's a strength and conditioning coach and he was
horrified.
He was like,
why the fuck would you ever do this kind of a workout,
like a super set workout for MMA.
It's like this is it.
This is really,
you were literally going to make your body work against itself.
You're going to stretch your muscles out below your muscles,
out in weird ways.
Stress out all you know,
like you're going to do bodybuilding stuff like bench presses.
It was really an interesting conversation and no one knows because what's good
for you is not good for him.
Everybody's got their own different way of improving their body.
But for Woodley he feels that he was not as exposed.
Like he listened to me,
people like me that were saying he's carrying around too much muscle and that it
was taken away from his explosion.
You know,
cause he was trying to like lean out a little bit.
So then he went back to it,
see how it is,
right?
That's Woodley's body type,
It's super explosive.
He might not have the best cardio,
but he's going to be a mother fucking beast to hanging out with for those first
two rounds.
Yeah,
the footage of him.
He's never going to be a Neil magni but he just has to do what he does best.
You know like Shane Carwyn he tried that too.
She aint tried losing all this weight and shit.
Try being a cardio guy and he just wasn't the same fight or man,
yeah,
you a,
you don't have what brought you to the dance,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
Stick what got you to the dance he had seen.
Even if Shit is interesting,
it's an interesting problem because if you fight and a guy like,
like Johnny Hendricks,
who's his next opponent,
great fight by the way.
Right.
But that's a great fight with,
if the fight goes into the third round,
can he compete at the same level?
Robbie Lawler,
you know Robbie Lawler can go balls to the wall for five rounds.
He can do it.
So if you try that shit in the first round on him and you're still there for the
second and third rounds,
you're going to be,
you know,
you're a different person now.
You're not the same guy.
You're a guy operating at 40% that's what you gotta do though with all these
maybe.
Right.
That's his best shot to win,
right?
First two rounds to be at your shit,
man.
Fucking demolition machine until you can't be a demo and they get taken out and
straight up veteran who can,
whether your store,
I'm like Glover with the Osm.
Oh speed.
I think you're doing great Ryan.
Thank you.
Tape.
When you talk to these strength coaches,
is there,
are there like three,
four exercises?
All of them agree are very important.
A lot of bodies,
you say that,
but Sergei Cola love,
he believes in [inaudible] the fucking one of the best boxers on the planet.
Yeah.
Kovalev does.
Yeah,
it does pull out easy power.
Yeah.
He does a lot of politics
because he wants to stay flexible and I'm a big range of motion.
Yeah.
He's,
he's into politeness and kind of interesting.
I thought because I've seen a lot of guys that are in a yoga,
I've never seen anybody that's into Palladio's,
right?
Rhonda did plot.
He's like yoga.
It's just a strengthening.
So Brian's nothing like yoga.
Let me know what you're talking about.
Yo actually lie down.
You have cables and equipment.
Yogas your own weight
line down.
If you've ever done to like that because it's a lot of these lot of housewives.
I'm going to ask that question.
I had court of law right now.
Pull out the height.
Does I pass it?
I've never even once thought about going in.
I've seen it being done.
Those chicks look like they're putting out almost no effort.
They say time.
I look in there,
I'm like,
this looks like maybe the easiest workout you can do.
Everybody comes out,
their body looks exactly the same.
Tell me he was a real athlete.
Told me it was no joke.
I can't.
I'm sure it's,
I'm fucking,
I'm fucking around.
I'm sure it's hard.
Here we go.
What's up
now?
You don't have to listen.
You don't have to.
We are going to bet on the main event.
Why aren't we,
oh,
if I lose this one,
you're willing to take Charles all know
which one we Breton out.
Brian.
I don't know.
They just showed he didn't look that yoked.
They just showed him standing there hearing highlights there.
There've been times where he's unbelievable yoke.
We just watched it as a wrong Eddie are you and Collin bed on the main event.
Okay,
Holloway.
I bet.
Oliveira you got Max Holloway Holloway all day for dinner.
Do you really listen Halloween?
Certainly when I don't want anybody to think that.
I think he's going to lose a fight.
I don't know what the fuck's going to happen.
I'm getting lost in silver as eyes.
I think I like the dreamy.
He's handsome.
He's a handsome.
It was the top three most handsome UFC fighters.
Brian.
Oh,
when Luke Rockhold without question rock called.
Let's go.
Well,
Eric Silva,
let's go.
I would have did this very good question and one of my favorite kinds of
questions
I have to say,
you see,
you got character,
you gotta throw character in the mixed.
Conor McGregor is women go nuts for Connor.
He's got style.
Cain Velasquez is not an ugly man.
Perfect proportions.
If he was shredded,
Sir Cane,
I had Luke Rocheleau have to ask you to step out of this conversation.
If you're in [inaudible],
has [inaudible] have to ask you to take a step for Dumas.
Reyna.
Interesting facial.
Just take the bench for a second and
ask you to stand down.
Sir.
I appreciate your enthusiasm,
but right now you're disrupting the chemistry.
Your top five count.
I got to go with my boy shop.
You've got to put shop and top five.
Oh,
you're tired.
It's late.
Not officially retired.
What do you base that on his high shop eyes when he walks
in
the crates.
A Humphrey.
I epidemic.
Man,
it's nuts.
You gotta.
You gotta go shop.
He's just a,
he's bigger.
He's bright.
He's very,
very,
he's Veit out and a,
and he walks up to Pete.
Pete.
It always holding his breath when he walks and you got to get out.
Eric Silva,
Eric Silva's gotta be put in there.
Yes.
No scalp
at the top.
I love to tell me.
I just can't give them top 10 oh man.
But I'm speaking aesthetically as a connoisseur of the male physique and face to
face without the face just body weight.
We all agree that Luke Rockhold is number one.
We all agree the only reason why anybody gets latest,
because Luke Rockhold didn't get that first.
Thank God
he should sell tee shirts with that on it.
We got to go.
Who's number two?
I mean,
this is a big question.
Well,
there's people that like a Chris Weidman and all American looking fella.
He's a cutie pie.
He's not top five.
Give them tough fight.
Robbie Lawler is overlooked.
Robbie Lawler's escape.
It's okay.
Daddy Henry,
how about this one?
Dark Horse,
Carlos Condit.
Yes.
By the way.
Too Skinny and he said,
excuse me,
I'm getting a number.
Tells him as far my book.
Yes.
I have to say,
I'm going to say Tyrone Woodley.
I got one Allen Joe Ban.
Oh,
that's not even fair to
might be number one.
He's number zero.
The only thing that separates him from Rockhold is rock holds taller.
We got to ignore him.
He's a professional.
He doesn't count.
He gets paid for that.
We're talking about regular guy that look at that face.
Goddamn beautiful man.
Jesus Christ.
It's a hell of a fight.
Perfect man.
Ryan.
I was staying next to a Marriott Hotel and he's just working out in the hallway
and I'm walking through it with my girlfriend job ahead and he's like working
out in the hallway with a trainer,
printing like the hotel hallway.
Just kind of getting somebody opens the donor,
I dunno.
Shirt off.
You had to bring him up.
He says Christ,
real conversation professional.
He makes Eric Silver look like some dude from the hobbit.
He does.
It looks like Lord of the Rings.
Now do Ben is is Dubin still fighting and he's talking about shallow fight or
podcast.
You got to do a little research son.
I am.
I'm just,
I'm just thinking just karate.
When I was 12 I've researched,
just wanted San Diego.
His body guys.
Yeah.
His body.
No,
even in my top five anymore.
His body kiss my ass.
He looks like a natural athlete.
Yeah,
he does,
but there you go.
You can keep that poor facial hair.
He's good looking guy.
He's not making my top five comment.
I got conduit.
We got the Bronco carnage.
You,
Bam,
Bam.
Allen's number one.
[inaudible] number one.
Really?
Yeah.
Alex count.
You can't count.
Count Him.
He's a prefab 11 five 11 is not the,
it's no,
I can't give it over stuff there for the six foot three Luke.
I can't do it,
my friend.
Yeah,
but that's the only thing that Luke has overall.
Be facially,
he's like a 10.
I like my mentor,
but I like my mentor.
I like them to tell her pants off my head.
I got to go with,
I got to go with my man.
Well,
if you want to count that,
then you know who's the hottest announcer?
Even Levine.
Joe Rogan.
No,
no,
no.
I'm sorry.
The ring announcer.
Oh,
Bruce buffer.
He's the hottest thing for sure.
Is the hottest man pay slick.
Well,
it looks like a fucking James Bond character.
Mergel Yada.
Come against.
Wow.
Eric is smooth as fuck.
He does not look,
oh,
this is the shit.
Right.
This is interesting.
You know,
he's lost a lot of muscle mass to you.
Kidding me.
A young Wilmer Valderrama.
Now,
do you think that he's lost muscle mass because he's trying to be leaner so he
has more cardio because that has been his issue.
Yeah,
that could be it too.
Or do you think this is a ped issue?
Should be bold.
The shop you specifically for the press?
Yeah,
for TMZ.
That's tough,
man.
It could be both.
I mean it could be right because it could be a combo,
but you have to consider it and we'll hear machine into the aggression like
Aubrey was talking about.
He's just not,
not as ferocious right now.
It's not some fucking big bombs right now.
I don't know what you guys are talking about.
No,
he was,
he just took a big deep breath.
He was,
he used to be super aggressive.
Dude.
You see the fire
spinning elbow.
He has to be careful too because Neil's number one things cardio if you're
hearing Sylville.
Exactly.
The worst thing is your cardio and Neil has a good ground game man.
He's fucking real good on the ground.
Super solid on the ground.
I'd say purple belt.
Yeah.
Solid Damn.
To say that after a Damien Maia fight,
yes,
but other than that,
he's looked awesome on the ground.
He's got a good ground,
but look a little too high,
but you know there was a wild scramble there.
Oh,
it takes him down.
Plot Fair.
C'Mon.
C'Mon,
c'mon,
c'mon.
Well,
for a guy like Aaron,
he's,
you know when you fight a guy like Matt Brown and Matt Brown,
just out work some down.
Beautiful Sign.
That's a sign of some dark shit on the ground for magnate right there.
That quick,
that fast.
There's a big difference of groundwork right here.
He's got a think.
He's got to also think after the Maya fight,
that mag is a little suspect on the ground.
I had this passion to weak side.
That's Neil's biggest.
If you have to pick something that's on purpose,
grappling off his
back office back when Neil,
just so it goes a cardio machine.
He's the same guy for every round.
That's so big.
If he could just add the other skills on top of that,
that cardio that he has is such a giant advantage.
Hopefully mentally,
let's say he were to lose this fight,
worst case scenario,
and he's lost two in a row.
He can,
he's come up a seven fight win streak.
What a change.
You go from seven fight win streak that losing tune or out within two weeks.
Yeah,
that's true.
I think in a certain point you need to be known for some kind of offensive
weapon.
Like they got to watch out for this or that because you've been blasting people.
If you don't have that fucking special power or two or three,
you're not going to be able to hang at the top.
The top echelon that they're worried about,
you know I called Cardio though.
He's got a lot of car.
It took them that a certain distance and now he needs some fire with exactly
what I said.
Hit me his head coach Lisa,
we're talking.
I said,
you're going to get to a certain point with those cardio's and winning off
points.
You didn't get a bad motherfuckers going out.
Nah Man,
this ain't gonna work.
Damien.
Maia was like,
Oh,
you're good at comedy.
Doesn't care about your cardio and silver here.
So over here is looking good.
Oh look at this magazine
full mouth.
Fuck.
Look at this shit.
Come on man.
Magni looking good.
Don't look into that second hook sign.
This control son under hook on the left side gives them that second Herrick
under her
tracks.
He's going to get down to the ground.
Either way.
This is good for Neil.
This kind of,
this is all this as a wound is gone.
This is good for Neil.
What's what we're saying about like the Matte Brown fight that Eric just could
not keep up with Matt Brown.
So for a guy like that,
like he's got to realize now that he's been there before and he's drown.
You got to realize,
okay,
I got to figure out how to be able to sustain this.
If it's possible,
how can be this shit?
Maybe he's going to be fine with this cardio.
Like he watched that fight and I'm sure it's corner set.
Do we got to get your cardio together?
If there were smart they would be honest with them.
I think it's kind of a power thing though too.
Like if either your cardio guy or you're not like Neil's never can be a knockout
artist.
He's always going to be a,
that's true.
Things came,
knocks people out.
Robbie Lawler knocks people the fuck out.
Well,
they have both.
They have both.
Like came to garner Nogueira bigfoot Silva.
Yeah.
I mean he should have,
I mean he put a fucking,
whoa.
Oh
Shit.
Oh Shit.
Levine taking a close look.
Legal man let that shit go.
He's a good one for that.
He does let things go.
I may have Gustafson in my top five handsome guys are still on that Sun.
That's a thing you have for Europeans.
That's not always,
he's a handsome Tony Bro.
Honestly,
he's got a perfect Swedish phase,
perfect genetic sex,
but he's not really ripped
muscular like that vampire from true blood
women,
you know in Sweden for many years,
they sterilize kids that didn't have symmetric,
perfectly symmetrical faces.
That a fact.
It's actually nice.
That's awesome.
Shit.
That's why they're so good looking because they stick at all.
No,
no.
Look into it.
You think that you think that's crazy?
When you say look into it,
did you look into it?
I got my brother was from Sweden and he hasn't,
he's
not at all.
It looks like state.
They had them in the woods and they kept him from the fishery.
That's crazy.
Crazy.
This is all you need to do.
Just Google it and pull up some studies and some peer reviewed papers.
That's what we did.
She had a phone right in front of you,
brother.
I started off with,
this is what I heard,
but I'm not saying it's true.
I have looked
bullshit.
I don't know.
You know what?
If I choose [inaudible] dot com says that Swedish jails or pick up the best
place it can be.
If you Google Swedish eugenics in like the 1930 [inaudible] at first I didn't
say what's true.
I just said,
hey,
there's some rumors out there.
Alright,
here's the sacrifice.
Shit.
Hell,
let's see.
Let's see if Eric could,
silver gets 60 planes.
Silva's hands are very low here.
It's very,
so it's highly fights.
These,
this first like two minutes,
super dangerous for Neil silver.
Looks like I get them down looking for that spinning back kick to the body,
but didn't land it.
He looks like he's so open to get punched in the face.
He doesn't look tired at all
while he's gotta think he got must have done some serious cardio or is ignoring
his fault.
Magni looks exhausted.
So controversial.
Magni always looks exactly the same.
And every fight he's always in shape.
Yup.
What does he do for Cardio?
He just trains nonstop man.
That his strength coach Loren Landow hasn't sleds and fricking sprint's has ever
been knocked out.
You Know Maggie?
No.
Oh,
I saw him in the video of cats and Ghana.
No,
the video.
A training.
Yeah.
They have a whole crew.
It's like Brandon Thatch.
He got his hurt.
He got hurt to the body there.
Look at that.
That's where it Cardell comes into play,
man.
He recovered way faster even from how much of it advantage train it down to
Denver.
That's gotta be an advantage.
You know,
I was one of the things I had a comment con a conversation with about Novitsky.
I'm like,
what about altitude tents?
How come they're not cheating?
How much of an advantage?
But he had a good comeback,
Joe,
because he goes,
I don't think it's that much of a scene.
It's not the same as when you travel and then so you're in Vegas or wherever
you're going to fight for a week.
That all that should equalize is out in like three days.
What do you mean?
Well,
I brought my,
I mean all the know,
all the benefits that you have of training to altitude is that true dissipates
within three days.
Eight days.
And,
but guess what I did take,
I would bring a hyperbaric chamber wind guys,
this is a thing called the internet.
And before you go on podcasts and you say,
I heard Oh,
Sam from my ex got Dan eugenics studies.
Oh,
Google.
Sweden.
Big Foot.
That's why they're so low back kick.
They cheated Google Dong Life.
I want to get a tattoo.
Eric's putting it on right now,
man.
I got to sleeve tattoo.
You should get something on your face.
Maybe tear drops or a heart.
And she got knives everywhere I command doesn't,
uh,
yeah.
Should do what I do knives with Jason Chasing Ellis did Tattoo the whole top of
your head.
You'll see I have a different animal.
Do a tiger polar bears some shitty
shit.
And elephants they seek to cover over the dumbest because nobody would know what
a
Shitty
fucking dodge.
Just so I can be a dick.
A bashing.
Anybody have a snail tattoo?
Oh I bet there's,
there's gotta be dudes that are obsessed with snails.
Like who I like to go.
I like a good snail myself.
Let's see Neil Magnus,
God on that foreign snails.com I like googling the tattoos that incorporate body
parts like armpits or vaginas are like assholes.
That right there.
Oh Shit I get that was Elliot Marshawn down?
Christian Chanel.
Jesus.
Brian.
Sorry.
So who's that?
Oh,
oh Maggie thrown up.
Triangles passing.
Oh
norm.
Good rich
holding.
He turned it off.
It was everything.
There was chores,
everything.
You got a little hungry right there.
Yup.
And look at this nice narrow stance by Eric Silva.
Catch that breath son.
His legs look so different.
His body looks different for sure.
But does it look bad though?
But he's doing well in the fight.
It really could be that he changed up the way he trains and he does more
conditioning stuff,
aerobics stuff than he does strength stuff.
Physically.
He does look different.
Cut a loss to weight.
You know the other thing he's got to realize or you've got to,
we all do is that he's a guy who caught a lot of weight to make one 70 probably
realize,
I can't fucking do that anymore without the ivs.
There's a lot of these guys are going to have to lose a tremendous amount of
weight.
They're going to have to lose like 10 pounds of muscle.
Yup.
There's a lot of guys are going to have to lose to keep going to be a different
person,
different person,
different fighter,
different results.
It's wonder how many guys at different weight classes out though less weight.
They had a cut because they already lost a lot of weight.
It might just even itself
out.
Maybe less a torture to the body.
Less trauma to the body.
Yeah.
That's possible.
That's super possible.
Having a tough time losing weight.
No,
he literally trains year round like a gazelle running nonstop.
Never gets hurt in the gyms.
Never.
That's amazing.
I know man.
He lived with Nate.
Mark Cart all three years.
It's part of them all the time.
All the time.
Oh Jesus Christ.
When the first round,
cause Eric Silva has got the second one.
I think it's one one probably.
Is He American as East Africa?
Magnesium's American.
He's from Chicago and he was in the service.
I think guys that have been to war and guys are in the military.
There's a different consequence to your discipline.
Like a guy like Tim Kennedy.
Is it different?
He's got a different kind of discipline.
It's like a tried and tested in battled discipline.
I just think there's an advantage to having that.
You just don't see a lot of guys that have that high level discipline and
military background.
Get an MMA guy like Colt and Smith.
You've got a few guys that have done it.
Stan,
Stan of course.
But Stan and I think Tim Kennedy or the highest profile,
the fought at the highest level.
You don't have to worry about their metal.
And Kenny,
we're talking about talking to him and he said,
and his buddy was there and he said,
you're never seeming nervous.
He said,
because he doesn't get nervous,
but it kind of makes sense for Guy Tim Kennedy who's been through such extreme
life and death circumstances and now it's just a fight with means you'll break
your nose or whatever,
and for him it's like it's a competition.
It's fun.
Well,
what you were saying,
it was the craziest fucking thing where you guys were revealing on your podcast
that Kennedy is still involved in military operation of the spear stuff that's
fucking up that same Columbia break.
A couple of tip.
That's fucking crazy.
Insane.
That's crazy.
[inaudible] he's in the UFC right now and he's still doing conventional special
option.
Yeah.
Hi.
Locking nuts.
Not,
not like,
you know,
he talks about when he talks about too,
it's like,
yeah,
go on.
Six missions at night.
Half of them are gun fights,
like
his best friend,
his best friend died four days ago when we did the interview.
It's no cheese operation and an operation he was involved in,
right?
Yeah,
he was.
He involved in that one lesson there.
He wasn't there for that one.
Talk about that.
Okay.
Podcast talked to them.
That general,
you can't reveal details,
but it's amazing that he's still involved in those operations.
Amen.
Where's my money?
When Tim Kennedy knock,
when Tim Kennedy knocked out half fail in the towel at the military base,
the fight for the troops does one of the most emotional moments I have ever seen
any fighter ever experience inside the octagon.
It was incredible.
He just jumped on top of the cage.
There was no cameras on them that we were gone to commercial and he was pointing
to each individual.
People in the audience just kept saying it.
I love you.
I love all of you.
I mean,
they were screaming for him and you scream for it.
It's a bond that he had with those people,
talks about it.
He talks about the Oh dude.
He level of bonding.
When you can smell somebody in the dark,
you know what they smell like in the dark.
That's what he said.
He goes that way and you've been through life and death situations.
I don't think that's a big thing.
Smell.
I don't worry about trying to be dramatic.
We're just glad.
I'm just glad dudes like that exists.
I'm glad that he ships.
They're the ones that they're the gatekeepers.
Yeah,
he,
you know,
he's a different,
he's even a different athlete than Jon Jones or any of the top athletes in UFC.
He's a different type of,
Oh shit.
Eric Silver.
Oh,
Neil,
go crack there.
Oh,
Neil magnet comes back with the knee.
You know,
I'll tell you one thing,
if I was hanging out with Tate and Joe and one of them farted,
I would know who far.
That's all.
It's a garden guy in the dark
smell.
But Tate's might kill you.
Yes.
No.
That was in my defense.
That was when Eddie was my dietitian
going like seven 11 before we get on a plane and be like,
Ooh,
this one's got Maltitol it.
Let's get four of those.
Eat those and sit next to Joe ideas.
I need a bunch of Kimchi and then want to tall apparently makes you fart.
Look at this.
Eric Silva trying to get her magni man,
he just can keep that.
The only time Magna's been in trouble like where we got t code was in the,
on the ultimate fighter by my switch stance in his regular UFC career.
He's really not been broad.
No,
cause it's cardio.
So damn good.
How's Richie doing these days man?
He's fighting.
He's fighting in Titan.
Is he doing well?
Yeah,
I think he's done.
All right.
So talented kid.
I always wondered why I never made it back to the UFC.
Will tighten owns over.
The UFC owns tight now.
Right?
So he's fighting with Titan.
So is that a recent deal?
Yeah,
they just,
they thought available on fight pass.
That's amazing.
Crazy,
right?
It's like a feed or leak and it's not cool.
Shooto Brazil's on Invicta.
I think Jason Chambers is doing commentary for shoot Tub Brazil.
Huh?
I chased column header.
Text him right now.
Yeah,
right to right now.
Jason,
sorry.
One Minute 50 to go here.
And Neil magni looking fresh as cheesy.
So we come on,
he doesn't,
she's got steel is Neil.
Maggie looks fresh as a daisy Macy's shopping foods.
She fucking good shape.
Oh my God.
That fucking look at their
take down easy.
Wilting.
The wilting risk control son.
Long legs.
This is a big difference between Neil Magni and Eric Silva as far as how much
you can keep this up.
It's crazy.
That cardio man.
That is nuts.
Oh my friend.
Oh Shit.
Is that what she wants you mom,
that just equalize that shit.
Hell yeah.
Hey,
they equalize each other sort of.
Yeah.
It has so far.
Eric's silver Atlantic way more shot.
Oh,
your crowd.
They showed the numbers,
took him down.
He hammered him five or six times and zero strikes.
Are you watching
in the middle of googling?
Eugenics is squeezed.
Make occasionally when Eric Silva was on a rampage
head down like that.
That's a good setup.
I get my information at the library guys.
I go to the library.
Apple bottom.
I'm so Bob [inaudible] who goes out library,
go to the library.
You guys get your information from the Internet.
I go to the library.
I love horror.
I love how you see the Internet as if it's all the same source.
I go to the library.
I read this,
the very different,
these different websites on the Internet is accurate.
What was the last time somebody went to the library?
Some guy asked me the other day if I wanted to have someone who is a law,
a flat earth proponent is apparently the best argue or for a flat or I want to
hear that argument.
What could they possibly say?
No fucking way either trolling or retard is weird.
Of course it's Trump,
but the one thing that's fucking weird is you would think with all the
satellites we have going in and out of our solar system and how come there's no
pictures of the earth and like,
Hey,
I don't know.
Oh,
it's a fat come Brian.
Yes,
they don't
Google pictures of the earth.
The earth.
You're going to see round earth.
You're going to seek as a CGI cartoon.
You know what it might be?
What you would think that'd be all these weird pictures of like the sun here,
the moon.
There'll be thousands of Hebron trapper keeper.
When I was a kid,
first of all,
first of all with the satellites,
they're all inside of 400 miles out,
most of them at least,
and then when you get past that,
they usually don't take pictures and they take a few.
I think they would take a voyager one.
They show the earth when it's like a little tiny dot.
And the distance I,
if I'm wrong in there is like thousands of pictures of earth.
There's just all these weird like the sun here,
the moon,
I don't know
why are you arguing with satellite like that far out and take pictures.
They've only sent a few of those out there.
They've only sent a couple different satellites.
No,
but sure.
There is hundreds of pictures on the Internet that you can see of the earth with
the sun in the background,
the Moon,
moon,
Sun,
but any,
you can see the earth rounded from space.
It hit the bench maybe has never been
more controversial beginning.
I just want to see because there's no where that literally if we're that
is not,
it's not a joke.
I hope this is all bullshit for sure.
Oh,
I hope
usually I can kind of everybody out Eddie.
But yeah,
that the earth is so ranch or photos.
Those are cartoon photos.
There's the one real photos and the Apollo 11 moon missions.
Ooh,
we got some decision.
How did that happen?
Wait,
who won?
Neil magni plans at home or nothing?
Olivera Holloway Holloway Grant.
This is,
this is
always good.
This is the amazing shit.
The one,
the,
the pictures of earth from like that could be flat space station shit can be
flat.
Okay.
There's a bunch of pictures.
Fuck that.
Did you say out the two jumps?
Is that what that is?
Just I think it is.
Yeah.
So Red Bull,
red bull guy right there.
Did you ditch third grade or
now
did you take that day off when we were talking about earth or
what did say
I love it.
Dammit.
Maybe I'll just pay you $1,000 double or nothing,
man.
Just paying a thousand.
You don't want to keep going do 2000 I'm some stupid fucking bet.
Well,
you could just do the Hallock Gracie method and just pay him and private
lessons.
That's pretty good too.
Private license,
be nice to,
that gives me a nice Jesus Christ,
isn't it?
It's not his fault.
It's on.
No,
it's all his fault and they send it.
I don't know who to believe.
I don't know what's going on.
Let's not start shit here.
It's not his fault.
So Brian tried poaching athletes from Ebi.
I knew that it's still going on.
I thought you settled that stopped.
I thought,
I think you guys are cool now.
Fuck no,
no,
no.
Fuck No.
It's ugly.
Cause I heard you guys.
Hey listen,
I don't,
I'm not going to like,
hey,
how come you stopped using the crowd?
Like how come you stopped using a crowd for Brianna Morris does it in black
house so that they don't have a big overhead now so they just get paper view
smart.
Huh?
Let me think about it because that's terrible pain
with no audience.
That's like having a concert.
Let's have a fucking festival,
but let's not have the audience.
I think that was it.
I'm thinking about doing that.
I'm thinking about doing it alone.
Oh my God.
He just felt just you alone with me.
No opening act,
no camera,
no camera.
Listen,
I'm just gonna record it on my iPhone and if you're not feeling right,
if you have an event and nobody shows up and no one's shows up to be in the
audience,
no matter what happens,
I show socks.
You know what I mean?
But he's making that happen because he wants to do,
he's doing it.
Pearl says,
especially with this foreign is a lot of good actors are that it's nice if you
could pan down,
go god,
there's Hixon Gracie,
or I don't think it's a good life.
I know what we're talking about.
A Nice thing to fill.
We're talking about what the UFC should do,
what the commission should do and what this
show should do.
I don't think that's a good move from at metamorris.
I want Metamorris to succeed.
I hope that I can beat it in Metamorris.
It's a good thing that we have all these shows.
I'm not against Metamorris.
I just think he's making a decisions,
bad decisions.
That's how I really believe in.
I think the majority agrees with you.
Yeah.
You know,
and uh,
I think it's why he would love that there's a show out there and there's going
to be super fights,
uh,
being put on.
I'm not against that shit.
That's how you might think you're just a second effect.
Ed,
here's,
here's the thing about Ebr though.
You've thrown a monkey wrench in the whole game with us overtime scenarios,
those,
it makes everything so much better.
You know,
first I was like,
how's this gonna work?
This is when you were telling me about it.
I didn't,
I didn't have the vision,
but then the first time I went and saw it live or want,
that's the,
what's so powerful.
It's the way it's the hunter because you would go through these matches,
they would hit 20 minutes and it'd be no finish and that would be the end of it.
But now there's a finish and a whole lot of those matches.
And if there's no finish,
it's still crazy because you,
you're almost getting finished cause you're starting off in a three quarter
position.
You start off with your back taken over on there,
been to one
shoot.
The best grappler show ever been by far the best grappling show.
It's the solution to the problem.
Everyone tells me it was amazing.
Eddie.
No hiding there in that it's not just no hiding.
You're putting in danger,
you're put in danger.
It's like everybody gets putting people to go to overtime and the people,
most of the reviews have 90% no shit have been super positive.
It's incredible.
I can't believe it.
That's amazing.
The Internet,
it's incredible.
Just nothing but positive,
positive,
positive and occasionally people say,
I hate the overtime rounds.
They suck because it's not fair that we put,
you know,
you're going to get a guy who couldn't pass the garden,
couldn't get his back naturally.
Now you're going to take me to,
over time you're going to put that guy on the back who couldn't earn that on his
own.
Like,
who cares?
We're just trying to make it exciting.
It's gangster.
I want you to hate over time.
What?
You know what's really funny?
You hear that,
that argument a lot of times from wrestlers,
which is so ironic because wrestling in,
they'll start on their knees with guy behind them again,
one hand and their waste.
What are you talking about?
Like you start in a disadvantage position all the time and it's a big part of
high school and college wrestling,
but at a,
you didn't lose any of competitors,
right?
You guys are all good now.
No,
he did.
I did.
Oh,
you did one contract.
He went after he went after a Ebi.
Ebi Three was announced.
It was the one 70 welterweight and the returning champion was,
it's Gary Tonin.
He was coming back for sure.
And uh,
I'm Dillon Dannis,
who I didn't,
I didn't even know who Dylan down it was,
to be honest with you.
I don't really keep up with what's going on in the Geeky Ibj JF Shea.
I really don't.
You'd have to be a superstar for me to know who you are.
So Dylan Dennis comes to me,
he comes to my school and says,
I want to go into Ebi.
Want to go against Gary?
Tony,
I think I could beat him.
And I didn't even know he was,
I go,
ah,
I can't promise you anything,
but you know,
let me look into you.
And now he came and he trained and,
and I looked into him,
I'm like,
Holy Shit,
this guy has a freaking freak brown belt who's killing everybody in absolute.
He just went gold after go.
Just tapping everybody.
My Hell fucking yes.
Texted them and go,
you're in Sun.
And then they started talking Shit,
Gary Tonin in Dallas,
Dylan,
Dennis on the Internet on Facebook.
I hope I get you in the first round.
Blah,
blah blah.
So there was some height building.
I'm like,
this is a foreign perfect.
And then how it comes in and offers Dylan,
Dennis and Gary Tonin,
uh,
exclusive contracts,
Dylan bar a bit.
And Gary said,
Fuck No.
So he almost got them both.
Both my,
my top seeds,
he almost got to both.
And I was already hyping the show.
He got billion,
but he didn't get Gary.
Thank God the show went off.
And,
uh,
Gary ended up winning and it was a great show and it got great reviews.
So,
but he,
if,
if Gary would have agreed to this,
you know,
and with Alex says is anytime anybody brings this up,
he just distracts everybody and says,
Hey,
the UFC does exclusive contracts or I'm just doing what the UFC is doing.
It's like,
it's not about exclusive contracts.
You specifically went after my top two guys and my show and you try to ruin my
show.
But the UFC,
you're,
you,
you talk shit on the UFC then the UFC does that,
you know,
so what an arrogant.
It's a distraction.
He's distressed that you are the UFC.
Yeah.
You're not.
And seriously,
I at that point,
I dine of scarcity,
tearing a ne like stop it.
I thought we were cool.
I actually thought me and Alec were cool.
I thought we were working together.
I thought,
hey,
you know,
you need some mission specialist for your show.
Your show gets a lot of uh,
uh,
bad reviews because of the board.
And that's the,
that's the big problem with you just to,
just like Joe was saying in Jujitsu,
I like how do you remove the boredom from it?
Because it's like playing chess.
A lot of people really in the chest,
it's a,
it's a very complicated,
sophisticated,
a little game,
but you're not going to put it on Fox.
You'll never have it on Fox.
Although the game is,
has a lot of prestige and,
and a lot of respect behind it,
but you're never going to see it on,
on,
on TV.
How are Jujitsu?
Jujitsu is exactly the same way.
Jujitsu.
Good.
Jujitsu is very intricate,
very sophisticated,
beautiful delay.
They're using the Gooey,
that control button,
but you're just not going to put it on TV.
It's just too much holding.
It's just not going to happen.
You can't put,
it's like chess.
Even guys who know?
Did you?
So I noticed when I've been at Metamora black belts don't even like,
I don't even watch it.
They don't even watch it.
It's black belt legends don't even keep track of the moon,
the owls.
So that's the problem right there.
The problem,
you've got to recognize it and go,
okay,
if we want a show,
if we want to do Jitsu to,
to uh,
you know,
let's say get on TV or get to the,
to the highest platform possible,
we got to do everything possible to remove the big problem,
the board of the stall,
the whole suggest,
would you suggest,
um,
points for like,
I dunno,
I mean never member,
no matter what selling system you come up with,
right.
It's a point is a point is a point.
If passing the guard is one point or it's 15 points,
it's still your up and now there's no urgency to make the move.
Your coaches are going slow down.
You've got a minute left,
don't do shit.
Don't try to plug you pass the guard.
Don't do nothing.
The coaching is stalling.
You're the athlete.
If he's smart,
he stalling.
I feel like that doesn't,
five minute of that,
it's too short.
You can't have any points to study.
You did.
You can't have any points.
You got to eliminate the points you've got.
He's talking about points over here and God dammit,
karate background help me.
It's gotta be conventional karate,
taekwondo and there had to be an overtime that they determined a winner.
You fixed it.
You know what's the next show?
December 13 Austin tests in time.
December 3rd toss in Texas.
This one's going to be a special one.
I'm still piecing it together.
It's,
I can't really talk about it too much.
Way Too early.
Yes.
Ebi Five.
You can see Ebi through the Hallux going to compete in yours.
It's absolutely true.
He's going against Brown and shop.
Saw It on Twitter.
I'll all I'm trying to do,
I'm just trying to make Jujitsu entertaining.
Uh,
uh,
for the masses.
That's it.
You're joining.
Hey Eddie,
you're about to lose two grand on this main event.
My man,
I had ingredient I didn't agree to that last is on Bro.
I love that he's wearing glasses.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Will you take a check or check cash or check my,
you will take a chat cause I don't have the cash.
It's kind of weird that all vera comes out kind of class.
We'll do think
vision issues.
He should bad.
I mean it's,
it's weird.
There's vision issues are so bad that he wants to wear his glasses up until the
time when he gets in the AUC,
he's probably going to paying for it.
They're clear.
No,
no,
you don't.
You don't just engage.
He,
he's the world series of fighting world champ at one 70 he has 5,555 yet here's
these glasses.
You take them off.
He couldn't,
he can recognize you like he has to squint so bad.
Wow.
It's crazy.
It's so funny.
No,
he's just horrible eyes.
So he's wearing glasses to fight or not fight with contacts.
You have to kill the condition.
They can't fuck with contacts or Lasik.
They used to fight with contact lasik.
Either know,
they ask if you've had it,
it just wasn't banned.
Yeah.
Well,
lasix,
there's two different ways of doing it and lasix is the most vulnerable way.
There's another way of doing it that it takes longer to heal and it's like
actual surge structure with a p.
Right?
I don't know.
I don't remember.
There's two different,
I might,
I might be even saying wrong.
No,
you're right.
Six is more vulnerable,
but there's two different ways and one of the more common way,
you're not supposed to have contact sports because if you get rocked that,
that stitching or the tearing,
wherever the cut,
the scar tissue could open up and you're,
you're fucked.
He's,
that's usually a bad sign.
He was like in raptures I lads,
I,
he's probably listening to some Jesus music or something.
Do you know why it doesn't hurt when they laser your eyes?
Legit point.
Right?
Why?
Why isn't your,
I believe you have nerve endings in your eye.
You know why I believe that?
Because when I go into the Cryo Chamber,
my eyes never heard.
They don't even get cold
laser.
You're awake.
You're conscious lasik.
It was pretty freaky.
My man really freaky,
but not painful.
You wait a minute.
You had lasix and you can't find any more then.
Well,
no,
I had never told him I did it.
We just did you fuck Jesus Christ?
Oh No.
Now you're doing
two.
They're going to sue you.
MMA media.
Brendan Schaub lies under oath about Lacey.
I got it when I was playing football.
Oh my God.
So you lied,
you said No.
What are you going to do?
Oh my God,
we're going to do now.
Maybe you're kidding about getting lasik visa.
You must be kidding about getting it and I think you're kidding about it.
I maybe I'm lying.
Maybe he's lying.
This is all for entertainment folks.
I don't really think Conor McGregor doesn't have the legitimate international
intermediate intermittent belts with like you're crazy.
You don't think that's a headline?
I hope against the headline.
I want to literally already going.
Literally all of them are like,
we got down to those last time.
Is it possible for downloads?
Can't get any bigger.
I'm going to start doing some research and millions of downloads for this show.
Is it possible for Joey Diaz to do to impression of Conor McGregor?
Is that even possible?
Yeah,
possible.
You Joey would have to watch them,
but if Joey,
what I'm talking about,
you do an impression of Joey doing an impression of what kind of allowed you to
take pot cock sucker.
We're going to take over.
Who's done what?
I've done.
Done,
done.
I'm doing the shit file and
walked up.
Fuck.
Think about what the fuck.
Eddie Bravo.
I love how he calls you.
Your,
your full name.
Brennan it shop.
What's going on?
Brendan shot
shows him her actions are world class and if you've ever heard him do a Porsche
or a rottweiler,
it's about as good as it gets.
Can you do a portion Porsche there?
Come on.
No,
he does amazing
grizzly.
He does a sick Kodiak anesthesia.
I'll do a couple of noises.
Grizzly too.
Yeah,
the abdominal snowman.
That's that bitch from that.
That movie.
Was it the ring?
That's actually a big book.
Really?
Joints when he wakes up in the morning.
Oh my
God.
Didn't you say the Noguera has to have like someone to work on his back for over
an hour before he actually works now what does he do?
He gets a Thai girl to walk on his hamstring sorts of stuff.
You gotta do it?
Everyone told me.
Oh don't worry.
It takes them an hour just to,
just to get ready.
Like,
I don't give a fuck.
Wow.
This is a great fucking fight.
We're about to watch here.
Max Huddle,
by the way,
how fun.
He's got down fight companion and the best I was looking forward to this all
day.
I was immersed in girl activities.
My daughters and my wife saw this girl,
girl,
Girl Shit.
And I'm looking at that clock and six hours I get to be the man.
It's almost over.
We got 15 minutes of manhood.
We can talk manly shit,
talk shit to each other.
Brian's going to take us to dinner,
dude.
I watched him get an angel wings,
real housewives of Beverly Hills today.
Today I was working out in my little gym and uh,
it was on and I watched it and watched these bitches screaming each other and
watching these girls turn each other.
And Mike,
how bizarre are,
is this behavior and how bizarre is these women?
I'll watch that shit.
I will watch
the hot,
hot,
hot girls of loss or the hot wives of Las Vegas.
You're talking about wags wives and girlfriends of celebrities and man,
I just saw it on a bus the other day.
It was
probably so many shows,
pieces.
They're tired of lives.
Nobody wants that anymore.
Well,
if they fight,
it's good.
Here's a local meetups.
It fights torturing some poor guy that sucked into this existence.
I'm sorry.
Nobody wants to see the hot housewives.
I and there's a lot of that is spoken,
Dan getting dumb route and this is very important bro.
Who's up right now?
Who's up somebody hallway.
Hallway.
But who is up in the bedding here between you told me what did you,
what was going on $3,000 which fight double or nothing.
Did you bet on Maggie?
Maggie and then I,
yeah,
from the Magni fine.
No,
no.
500 now betting another down.
But we had another 500 100 cause it remembered you.
I won the 500 on clover.
Oh,
it's right on.
It's right here.
Damn.
He get he bet against clover.
Clover Versus Pat Commons is a tough fight.
What do you think about that fight?
Sick.
A bummer when Pat's my [inaudible] for Patterson.
The glove was just,
to me that's a big statement about how you feel about Glover.
I Love Pat Man.
I love Pat.
He's my closest train partner.
When we were,
when I was fighting,
you know,
and if I could pick a horrible matchup for him,
it would be clover to Glenn.
I don't know how he's going to win.
Super.
That breaks my heart to say it.
Super impressive.
Glover versus OSP super.
He's a monster and a cut like relaxed.
Oh,
you're a,
you're an amazing athlete with those crazy kicks.
That's well the only,
the,
the not the only chance,
but a good chance that pat can mimic his,
when he fought filled Davidson Brazil.
But that was a globe who was kind of like all worn down.
It was like eating fucking just veggies or some shit.
He was coming off of that was,
he was only eating veggies.
I just made that up.
He looked like shit.
He was coming off the Jon Jones fight and he hurt his shoulder pretty bad in
that fight.
I don't know what he did to fix it.
He never went through Sir Surgery,
you didn't look good.
And we are filters hung on warm out.
So I mean pat could do that for sure.
But you know,
it was all the striking.
He was training for that fight in Connecticut and a garage.
Remember like by himself?
Yeah.
They have the countdown show cause he showed him riding a stationary bike.
Listen,
the Aba like 30 so that's it.
37 he's a glow over is not young.
He looks every bit of 45 this is not 37 from six years ago when you could do
stuff and get away with it.
Right.
This is a legit 37 and that's not good.
But turned him seven.
Every boxer that's ever been good ever except for George form has done at the
same guy and done damn box at Bernard Hopkins.
But we don't know what Bernard Hopkins is doing.
I,
as far as the growth,
people don't think he's ever taken something.
You're fucking crazy.
I'm 50 50 is 50 and he's still winning.
Who said Bernard Hopkins?
And by the way,
his body does look different.
That may does look different.
Maybe in many ways,
one of the greatest sporting feats we've seen period.
And he's,
you know,
what else is good too?
Um,
like he doesn't seem to be diminished as far as like the building announcer.
Not Bad dude.
Shame been hurt.
Remember that.
Hey,
it's very good for him.
For being 50.
Yeah.
Y'All.
Oh for a fighter.
He's never been here we go.
His career,
you'll go Max Holloway and all the Avera.
See I feel like all Avera is more technical standing up and I think he's way
better on the ground.
But I think Holloway is so damn scrappy.
Yeah,
he was so confident.
A so wild like right there.
I love that.
Right hook the body and was straight left afterwards.
I was just so impressed with the way he took it to cub cap,
move in,
warm out,
heard him a couple of times,
almost finished and once and then finished and shot going right to the body like
that.
Well,
he's an animal man.
Max Hall was a bad mother fucker.
And the other thing about Holloway is he's young,
like 23.
When you get a guy like that,
you're seeing them every six months.
You've seen a way better version of this defense and that defense.
You chant even judge him by who we used to be six months ago.
He's probably way better now.
I think Charles is more dangerous.
I just think Max has,
I think he puts it together better.
That's why I think Mexican when I think he just throws it all out there.
He's like,
I'm just going to put all my train together.
I'm going to throw everything at them right now.
I'm not wasting shots.
Caution PJ eyebrow flash.
They have a common opponent.
Cub,
Swanson,
a cub,
Swanson Lit Charles of on fire and Max Holloway.
Um,
or yeah.
Then it comes to loss of,
stopped him early in the first round and then of course Max Holloway just got
the biggest card,
some down.
What's wrong with cub when they fought,
they didn't get hurt in the first round,
so I'm not taking it to get away from Max.
But what happened?
Oh Shit.
Oh fuck.
Oh no way.
Really pay me by about a,
Oh wow,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
What's going on here?
Located his shoulder.
Look at this college.
I pulled away from him immediately.
Wow.
Powerful Max Holloway.
It's too bad.
It would have been fun to see him go.
Yeah,
there was an,
it was shaping up to be an interesting fight,
but Holloway was teeing up on him already.
Damn.
I think I just lost 20 bucks.
Yeah,
man,
you did against me down 2000 would be lost to grant.
Got his collar bone.
It shattered.
Oh fuck.
Mans up bomber.
You don't want to see like that.
Like the God damn.
Can we get a replay or something?
Give us some volume.
Sun.
Give us some volume so we can hear and I just want the replay.
What they're saying,
why are his wings Tattoo differently?
Once a devil one's an angel,
Bro,
that's your words.
Go and just get me ready.
He just stopped and went,
I'm done.
Oh God.
Yeah.
Well he must,
he's a smart dude.
He must've known something was a cracked my check.
He says,
well,
you can't ask for a performance bonus for that.
I got an injury.
That's kind of silly.
It's a bomber.
Let's see what happened here.
Although it was interesting fight,
so he shoots eight hits.
The whole riffs.
Shoulder hurts right there.
Yeah.
Look,
look,
look.
No,
no,
no.
Let's do something else.
This was something else.
Oh No,
no,
no.
He gets up.
Yup.
That's it.
Hold a little bit.
No,
no,
no man.
It's Eddie.
It's off.
I'm not going to charge you that.
I'm not gonna charge you two.
Let's,
Oh,
you're a beautiful person.
Look at this.
He's am shooting for the tape shooting for the tape.
I would think he think he,
he,
he broke it something and then he didn't really feel the extent of it.
It splits be quiet.
Let's give us some volume.
Maybe we can hear Jamie give us more volume.
Wow.
He's,
hold on one.
I'll take whatever bet you you make the next bet and how it will be doubling up
and Molech.
Let's see what he said.
Well,
hits.
Hear what they're saying.
Main event.
Hold on.
He seems like he's grabbing his neck,
man.
It's like the collar bone thing though,
right?
I don't know.
It's fucked up that his nose started bleeding immediately when he did.
That shit doesn't look good guy.
That doesn't look like,
yeah,
no shit.
That was a neck thing.
It wasn't like it is call his boats kept going like this behind him.
Kept going like the carotid artery or something.
That's a bomber that doesn't count all bets off on that.
Well,
you're a beautiful person because Eddie Bravo would a stuffed it.
Right
if he wants to do the same thing.
That's not a real fight.
Well,
it was a real fight.
I'll tell you what.
I was super impressed with Holloway before that.
Before the ending,
he was really landing some nice shots stand up really well.
He's getting better.
He can be the champ.
We can be the chair.
Who didn't agree in that division?
Datsun Johnson.
Well we,
it has to be on a though.
Okay,
so we got up to him.
Okay.
Damn.
What a fucking is fucking collarbone fell off.
Well,
we hope that's what happened.
I'm,
I'm nervous that he was grabbing his neck.
Yeah,
I'm nervous that his next fucked up.
Is there any truth to that?
You can get hit in the neck.
They're like judo,
judo,
chop it up.
He saw it.
Man of mystery.
What do you mean?
Like he hits the neck and knocked out.
Oh,
was for sure kicks land the movies with the gun shot ganache.
Sure.
One of the most,
it's gotta be real apres talking about like the,
you know,
judo chop and hit them and they pass out.
Right.
Well apparently there.
What's that?
There's that,
there's that movie about that cold leader that was just came out and he killed
somebody with judo chops.
Apparently source the source family.
Really?
The guy from the source family?
Yeah.
I don't know what does,
he killed the guy with judo chops and then started a call with a bunch of hot
chicks who wore white.
You
there?
No traps in judo but,
but you know what I mean?
That we always see like the news in the newspaper clipping old an old judo.
There was Brian when I saw the Flintstones and they said,
Fred Flintstone said a judo.
Judo Chop comes from Austin Powers.
Judo.
No,
no,
no.
It has not come from [inaudible] decade.
It comes from Austin Powers is a thief.
He stole that shit from Fred Flintstone.
Source family judo chops right now.
All right,
perfect.
Judo.
Hey,
let's hear some volume gives me volume.
That's a bummer man.
Volume Bruce Buffer
for the official decision was here.
The official
set of Nipples on it at one 39 seconds on the very first round,
you're going to win by June.
Oh,
come on.
Why are they calling it a Tko?
That's ridiculous.
Why not medical stoppage?
Well,
do they revise that?
If they find out what happened to his neck or his collarbone or whatever,
you see what he says,
Hey,
you know,
I want to do like Bj and beat the champ.
When your thoughts on bringing it home in every way class,
boy,
everybody.
Is it part of the game and it's kind of sad to see
know.
So what?
What?
What is going on with all Rivera?
We don't know what the hell.
Yeah,
I'm trying to see it.
Fuck now that's scary.
Him saying that Kenny Florian,
Kenny flying says Charles.
Olivia hurt his neck when he went headfirst into the cage.
Wow.
For sure.
You Bet.
And I've stopped cause it was Stinger.
Lose my number if you stopped cause it's the right number.
He does she have your number.
First of all,
he doesn't even speak English.
Well you'd be surprised.
You'd be like,
you'd be Sabrina Shove,
you talk a lot of shits about Brazil and the Brazilian Internet.
They released all his information so everybody can hear you.
I get death threats from Brazil.
He's all the time.
One of the coolest moments was,
you know,
working for the UFC or running into these famous fighters all the time and would
Nogueira first came over.
We started talking and we exchanged numbers and I thought it was the crazy as
shit that I'm exchanging fucking Nogueira.
Yeah.
It was so weird.
We've never like exchange any text or anything after that.
It was kind of like this,
but it was,
it was really strange.
You know I said that Sam Stout retired.
Yeah.
[inaudible] his opponent.
The price.
[inaudible] opponent first UFC fight,
knocks out,
stamps out Sam's town and says,
I'm going hang on tight move.
Just wanted me to get there.
Not The gout bitches.
Save that head trauma folio Mama.
That's say that.
Hands out the old Mama on a bad idea.
It's a good tee shirt.
Head trauma for your Mama.
Let's see if the a g has a,
Oh,
here it is.
Here's the man and killed somebody with judo jobs.
Judo chops like Justin Wren.
He also calls himself father yoed Father Yod,
Holloway wins with the judo.
Chop her,
his wife and daughter to ride to Hollywood on a motorcycle.
Audition for the role of Tarzan.
Well,
yeah.
Well you may or may not kill someone with you to chest and shot him.
Killed a man.
Definitive that the abandoned his daughter but then killed a man so well,
and I'll just infer Tarzan.
There's a lot of,
um,
look up my guy.
It seems like your life or Gen X.
I'm jealous.
Eugenics.
Eugenics,
1930s.
So someone who is on your side on my timeline,
is it really?
It's for also robbed 11 banks.
He robbed 11 bags.
He sounds like he's robbing back.
Started a call free though.
Still free and running is called three and run is called.
They made,
uh,
one of the doctrines was you had to smoke weed for exactly seven second polls
from the bank.
I was like in the commandments,
you gotta go
back and then they would do Cooney,
Eleni Yoga,
get high and then talking to other,
that's hilarious.
Anything that part.
Yeah,
we're,
we're trying to find out what happened to,
uh,
Charles all Avera,
but I'm scared,
man.
I don't like that.
I don't like that at all.
Where to start.
Because if you're all amped up with adrenaline and sweating and your neck gets
hurt that bad,
especially early on when you have the nerves.
Yeah.
Like you said,
all the Adrenalin,
paternal Varma was Michael Bisbing saying,
cause he had some significant neck problems.
I call finally one and went down to one knee.
Well,
you both had taken Max Holloway before and then might ask away.
Whoa.
It only lasted a minute and a half,
four minute 40.
But what I saw looked fun.
Thanks Holly.
You Bet.
Dapper fucking Englishman.
Beautiful hair is a handsome guy.
And then moving
all of the right eye.
It looks a little suspect.
Oh yeah.
He's got some serious problems with his high.
He's got oil in his eye.
He's like,
dude,
dude.
At least he didn't punch him in the face there,
but he did hit him.
They know he's going,
no,
I'm done.
I'm doing.
He's like,
oh wait,
here's what for your liver.
Not done yet,
bitch.
So they sent me this thing for Eddie and they go between 35 and 76.
No fewer than 60,000 young Swedish women deemed mentally defective or otherwise
handicapped to a degree,
which makes them quote and capable of looking after their children or
sterilized.
Well,
that's not quite the same as looking back,
but continue.
They were ugly.
They caught him out.
I'm on your side,
brother.
The Internet's with you.
The Internet,
the Internet with the Internet.
And he never judged by the symmetry of their face.
The Internet may side like they thought that the symmetry of facing determined
how uh,
how um,
is that what it says online?
Are you just guessing?
I'm just guessing he did study faces to see if they had any correlation to
exactly criminal behavior.
That was brain.
No,
like skulls.
Right.
For Knowledge.
And of course that turned out,
I found out people are committing crimes.
If there's a way you could look at if someone's face and sad,
there are criminal of course there's no science to it at all.
Yeah,
of course.
Quite of course.
But they did it into that shit.
Actually a consent Sweden's for a while in Sweden,
I think it was actually in the United States,
but are light again,
is that main event Barmini out man,
they did that main event bum me out
well was that,
it bums me out because I'm worried about that dude's neck.
That's,
that's a real unusual man.
Joe Riggs was the last time that happened when Joe went down from that takedown.
But Joe so battered and beat up,
I just figured like,
yeah,
it was probably an old injury.
You got Charles says young man.
Yeah man.
Well we don't know.
We never know
you got out of this one.
Eddie.
I'll give you that.
My man.
Hey.
Well he got out because you let them out.
Yeah,
I'll pay you if you want me to know.
I don't want that tainted money.
Okay,
next by conveying and you pick the main event,
I'll pick if it's close.
If it's like Rhonda versus Holley,
we can't,
I'll take,
I'll take Holly Holm.
There's no way he's going to do a fight companion for Ronda Rousey.
I can't.
I'll be there.
I'll be there for that one for sure.
Unless it's in Yugoslavia was just making it like an exaggeration.
They decided to do it and check.
What about Barnett?
Roy Nelson in Japan.
There's no way you're going to that.
No,
not that I might be on the road.
I don't know.
It's always tough.
That's the only thing I came to my mind.
It's tough to get a stars align every now and then,
but it's good in that every now and then.
Yeah,
these are good and people are gay.
You guys talk over each other and you shit on each other.
Yes,
that's what we do.
That's what friends do.
But it's amazing how controlled it is.
Even in this atmosphere.
Booze,
weed gets a little cold.
It's amazing.
It Brian counts still tries to give Jiu Jitsu invoice.
That was the first thing I say and put Johnny Buddy or Chan pushed down and
that's what he said.
What you need to do in front of
you were the most qualified talking about most handsome man now
in this room,
100% but I mean,
and we still really haven't gotten down to it because you've got to go look.
You've got to go your boy.
Also,
I think what you're going to need to do in order to really tighten it up,
I would literally out of time,
we're probably done right?
Yeah.
We're already done.
We're done.
This is at three hours.
Eddie Bravo on Twitter.
Aubrey Marcus on Twitter.
Brian Keaulana.
Why on Twitter Tatum?
Maximize on Tait Fletcher full back.
Come on back.
Come on.
Who's got Tatum is maximum c to double double,
but I don't ever look at that shit.
Yeah,
the one you should post like for tickets or be dead post shit and whatever you
went with Brendan Schaub in the motherfucking house fighter and the kid.
When are you gonna bring back any Bible radio?
That's a good question.
All right.
I like podcasts.
Podcasts on it.
Podcasts.
So warrior poet Park Project.
All right,
that's it.
Fuckers.
We'll be back soon and we're probably gonna do an audit one from Texas this
week.
I'll be,
and I are going to go slay pigs.
That's right.
Not Cops.
That's rude.
I don't call cops pigs,
but real wild pigs.
I'll vera his neck,
his brace,
and he's on a stretcher.
They taking out back way.
He still grabbing his neck.
Whoa.
Oh my God.
Fuck.
All right.
Well all of our hopes and wishes are for Oliveira,
you know,
send them some,
some low at socks.
Hi folks.
Thanks for tuning in and that's it.
We'll see you soon.